I can't believe it. People are talking
about me in Discord servers. I cannot
believe it.
>> Butter buttered chicken and naan bread
is fire.
>> Well, I've got to What do you mean hold
me accountable? What do you mean call me
out? Howing dare you? It's It's just
crazy. I I'm I'm 12 years old and Indian
and have no idea what you're doing here.
Genuinely the worst I have ever seen
this guy.
>> So, hold on. Let me No, no, no.
Last night, Wick TV did like a 7 minute
stream, 8 minute stream called Destiny
versus the Snarkers part two, question
mark. Now, if you don't know, this is
all about what started off as like some
Splinter server of various communities
around here and turned into like sort of
a clipping community, you know, it's all
arising from that basically. And
obviously, there's a lot of people as as
you might expect in this community that
don't like Destiny. There's a lot of
lefties in there. They're not all
lefties, but there's a lot of lefties in
there. Um, and obviously a lot of people
don't like Destiny. And Destiny hates
the idea that there are people talking
about him who don't like him. And
there's evil things that happen in the
server, guys, like this. Evil things
happening in that server. So, basically,
this all triggered a massive just spur
out. Um, Willie Mac's been running with
allegations against JTalk on Twitter and
he's just like spuring about the server
as well. This is I think this is Starzy
from JTalks here. Um, everyone says me
is it
>> seen any reciprocation? So, I actually
don't know.
>> Yeah, everyone says me and this guy have
the same voice. I don't agree but
>> reciprocation. So, I actually don't know
exactly what the truth of that is. But
yeah, anyway, I do have to go. I'm
really sorry. Maybe
>> you have so much to say about me in all
your servers when you're not here now.
You're this meek loser.
>> I'm UK hours, bro. I'm UK hours. I work.
What do you want me to do?
>> How do you work and have all this time
to talk about me and talk about
everything related to me? so many hours
of the day.
>> Yeah, everyone says that we have the
same voice, but uh yeah, I don't I don't
really think so. I think that's like uh
bigotry. Anyway, basically Destiny
called in to tell Wick to blacklist
snarkers. Basically, no snarkers. No
snarking. No snarking. Finger wag. No
snarking. Finger wag. Wick needs to
blacklist all snarkers. And Connor saw
this. So he he didn't end up doing it
though. He basically came to compromise
with Destiny that he was going to remove
the recording in VC rule and the
streaming in VC rule so that whether
Destiny's on stream or not, he can um
join and fight people about you know
whether he sheds shares nudes without
consent whether he retains CSM in a way
that isn't conducive to his legal
responsibilities or whatever people want
to argue with him about you know any any
number of allegations doxing any number
of allegations any number of points of
controversy with Destiny. Um, now for
those who don't know that that's
actually what caused the massive fallout
between Chud and Wick really is people
recording his VC and Chud watching it on
stream. It's very funny that now Wick
goes back on that. Uh, it's also
hilarious that he's now saying, "Oh, I
got sent evidence of of my dogs being
spread. So now I'm on Team Destiny." As
if he wasn't always on Team Destiny. Uh,
it's took Never sent proof, by the way.
Well, I it was I believe it was there
was a message with it in the first two
weeks of that snarkle left server before
pe before many people joined before
there were any moderators and no one saw
it until it was brought up. People went
back through found it user was banned.
Users banned from everywhere basically
>> the tooth of Zion bows to King Fel.
>> Thank you for the $10. Huge appreciated.
So it's like handled the only way you
can. Um so yeah. So, so there was I'm
not saying he's lying about that in any
way. Um, obviously it doesn't make it a
doxing server. You know, this happens in
every Discord of a certain size. There's
always PII posted at some point. It's
just about whether moderators deal with
it or not. Unfortunately, that was
posted when it was just like [__]
no moderators, no one was paying
attention. Um, now what's hilarious?
Well, we'll get to it. You'll see in
this conversation there's something
hilarious about that, okay? About the
little double standard. Um, but anyway,
where was I up to? [__] So Wick's being
told to ban Snarkers and he chooses to
remove his recording rule. Connor sees
this and Connor is going to review it on
stream and talk about some of the stuff
that's going on and that's sort of where
we pick up. Um, basically this was about
banning Doobie. Really, it was about
banning Doobie. Um, now Connor's got all
his mind maps here. So Connor does this
little thing and he basically says, you
know, it's it's reasonable for you to,
as my friend, not want me to allow
people in my community to just endlessly
endlessly talk about you when it's not
even relevant and just constantly be
dragging your name through the mud. As
we're friends, I'm willing to, you know,
stop people from talking endlessly in my
Discord about how much of a terrible
person you are. But then Connor says
that he feels like underneath that ask
that Destiny's seemingly making what
what he actually means is since I have a
disproportionate amount of clout and
power in in spite of slash because of it
is safer to ban snarkers entirely. So
you do not warrant my wrath/
disassociation. That's and that is
pretty obviously what's being said
really. Um so Connor's talking about
that for a while but he does all these
war analogies. Um, I'm kind of sick of
just like like it con everything just
gets grouped into one man. Like because
when Connor talks like this does annoy
me when Connor talks about stuff he's
like, "Oh, you J Sners Kiwi Farmers, you
know, some of these people think it's
okay to go after Destiny's Kid. I don't
go after Destiny's Kid. I don't allow
people in my community to go after
Destiny's Kid. That's not a thing we've
ever done. It's not a thing we've ever
done. I'm sure you could find an
instance where something gets posted
about him, but as a rule that's not it's
not a thing. It's not a thing. People
generally feel quite bad for Nathan. I
think I don't even like addressing that
on stream to be honest. There's all this
freak [__] where he's, you know, going
and talking to Drew Pavlo and all this,
you know, no one wants to be involved in
that. No one wants to be [__]
involved with that. No one wants
anything to do with that [__] Not
around here anyway. Obviously, I know
there are total [__] freaks that do,
but that ain't us. That ain't me, you
know. it all gets lumped into one. It's
kind of [__] annoying. Anyway, we'll
get to that later, I think. But
basically, Connor saying, you know,
Destiny should be doing Sorry, it's all
these gay war analogies. But look,
Connor did a good job of, you know,
standing with a [__] spine today. So,
we'll indulge his gay [__] war
analogies. We'll indulge the Space
Marine argumentation, okay? Just for
this, just this one time. All right.
Redest Reddit post about you. I haven't
seen a Reddit post about me. You know,
I've heard I've seen Destiny's Reddit
post about Connor. I think that's the
one you mean though, cuz it mentions me.
I think that's what you mean, right? But
yeah, basically Connor is saying that
Destiny should be doing uh
counterinsurgency warfare. Okay. Where
you identify who the targets are
engaging in wrongdoing and then you
target them. I think a pretty reasonable
position, right? It's like you can't
just um you know, let's let's give an
example. Let's map it on. Let's say a KF
user uh doxes someone near Destiny. That
doesn't give Destiny license to go after
literally everyone who dislikes him and
talk [__] about him in Discords all day.
It it gives him a right to go after the
person who doxed the person close to
him, right? That's pretty pretty
reasonable position, I think. And it
should be a proportionate response,
right? Um, now here this is what Connor
says Destiny's doing, which is total
warfare where you just, you know, you
you burn the hatch roofs as he's saying
go scorched earth, target everyone. All
right, that's that's what he says here.
And then he's going like freed he
separates freedom fighters and
terrorists. He's talking about all this.
He's saying and Jay talk to themselves
as freedom fighters, but there's
terrorists in their ranks. It's like,
okay. All right, man. Again, I I would
just contest that it's about what you do
when you discover someone's engaging in
bad tactics. If I find someone doing
something that's against what's
acceptable, I I take action. Now, while
Connor's talking about this, and we're
not going to watch this cuz it's [__]
boring. Uh, resident [__] Mr. Mutton
calls in to say, "But but Connor, don't
you think you're being like a bad friend
by not just doing exactly what Destiny
wants immediately?" and he says that
he's going to ban any docs in DGG
because he holds them to a higher
standard. Now totally ignore the fact
that they that totally uncontested for
like the last year and a half they've
just like spammed doxes. It's all it's
all over Twitter all the time and
spamming doxes like it's literally
endless all day every [__] day. Now
obviously not all DJs obviously and I'm
sure not all DJs know about it or
approve of it but a huge amount of them
approve of it and there's a lot of them
doing it. Um, to suggest it's not a
cultural issue over there would be
naive. Uh, but anyway, Mr. Mutton
[__] sucks. Total brain dead [__]
Uh, Wick calls in and Dooby call in.
Like I say, I don't know how long I can
go for tonight. I'm really [__]
tired, so I don't know if I want to
watch all this [__] leadup. It's
quite a lot of time. It's quite a lot of
time. Like I said, went for like seven
or eight hours. But yeah, basically
Connor was saying Connor was just
putting his foot down and saying, "No,
I'm not acquiescing to every single
[__] demand Destiny makes of me." DG
is like insisting. So, I guess we'll
watch this bit because quite this quite
core to some of this. So, people insi
are insisting that Doobie uh justified
or encouraged people to a log and harass
Nathan. Okay, that that's what they were
insisting in Connor's chat. And so, they
get the clip and let's just see that I
guess. Anyways,
>> and his mom like he's around here making
these arguments.
>> Permission structure permission
structure for people to [__] with Nathan
to [__] with his mom. And I don't agree
with that
>> and his mom like he's around here making
these arguments
>> permission structure permission
structure for people to [__] with an to
[__] with his mom and I don't agree with
that to be clear which is why I don't
think any of it should be happening but
I just want to be clear like if if that
is what the world that he's he uh is
creating like I don't think he has any
ground to complain about it.
>> Well wait so first there's like two
things here. It's just like whenever
like we're talking about some like
unhinged person's behavior, you're
always pointed like, well, but kind of
like but Destiny did this and then it
doesn't even seem that equivocal. Where
did Destiny tell you it's okay to dox
people's family's children or any of
that?
>> Okay, this is a [__] question and
I'm going to go ahead and react to it.
is if you dock somebody, if I live with
my family and you have my phone number
and you have a picture of my face and
you have my address and you have my
employer, how hard do you think it is to
find extended family members? Sometimes
it's as simple as white pages or yellow
pages. It's literally not hard once you
find one person to find their extended
family members. And let's say that
somebody wanted to come to my house in
order to commit homicide. Well,
sometimes my family is going to be
present. Don't you think?
Like it's it's just a loose connection
where this guy is like directly saying
like hey it's okay to like u yeah it's
okay to like target
>> if if you get or what you're saying is
basically in by Destiny standards it's
uh by Destiny standard it is okay for
people to attack his son because if
you're like involved
>> Yeah. correct. So everybody who docks
Destiny also docks his entire extended
family. Yeah. Absolutely. Yeah. That's
true. Did Doobie do that?
Did Queenman do that now? Maybe JTO did.
I don't [__] know. But that's why we
want throwing J to the wolves
immediately.
>> Want the logs, right? We want the logs
because we want to know who's doing the
doxing. So if somebody docks Destiny,
Yo, thank you for the £10, Septic.
Hugely appreciated with the game
controller character with the deal with
it glasses falling down. Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
>> Hear me when I say this. That is bad and
evil
and it puts Nathan in and Destiny and
his entire family at risk. Of course,
you [__] [__] And don't tell
[__] you. Hold on. How about this? We
got like 400 people in here. I'm
literally just going to sit here for 30
[__] seconds because [__] you. That's
why. Don't tell me how to stream.
>> This skip
for 30 seconds. But Connor, honestly,
Connor, if you like I already like
Connor, you know, I'd still have issues
with Connor cuz I do I do think he is
biased and I do think he's dented
sometimes and I disagree with him a lot.
But if you didn't like Connor, he's very
endearing at many points in his stream.
Yeah, this is the other thing that
Talibots [__] zog [__] who goes on
Wick stream all the time was saying
Queen and his audience think you're
pathetic, Connor. They're they're using
like a local cow or some stupid [__]
like that. Dude, people literally the
response to Connor coming on for the
interview. But we we l First of all, we
treat everyone like that. Okay. Everyone
gets treated when they're doing
something silly or when they're
embarrassed as as a as a bit of a cap.
We like having a laugh at the spectacle.
Second of all, literally the response to
the interview was like glowingly
positive. Everyone was like, "Oh, dude,
I actually like dude Connor's cool.
Yeah, I was on the fence about Connor
before, but literally it was just like
completely positive across the board.
People like laughing while it was
happening, but you go look at the
comments. You go look at the comments.
People loved it. But I think that's just
something she heard on food shops. I
legit think people just watch this like
[__] Chinese pedophile give a
[__] like awful read of social
situations. Iterated your [__]
position. So, hold on. We still got a
few minutes in the We got five minutes
total. Do you have five minutes? If you
don't if you don't have five minutes to
hang out and react, that's totally fine.
I'm just uh
>> No, it's okay. all in their people's
prolifer
that does not there is a very very like
reasonable like assumption that that
doesn't mean like they're 14-year-old
kid or anything like that.
>> Yeah. Well, so that's the other thing. I
would literally I could never hate
Connor because he got me the Brianna Woo
interview and and he and he recognized
the game. He recognized the game I put
in cramming a [__] you know, editing
editing a hit piece within a week time
span that drop on the same day. He
recognized the the game. So, you know, I
could never hate Connor.
>> Wait, why? So, so the so the issue is
that he's putting these people in
danger, right? So, I'm sure esports
Batman has a family. I'm sure Jay-to has
a family. Quean has a family. He stalks
both of them. I'm sure Wicked Supreme
has a family. And any
>> dude, literally none of these [__]
ever could. What do you mean the address
could never? None of them could. None of
them could. Okay, these guys take six
months to make anything.
>> Internet community is going to have
crazy [__] people in it, right? It's
some of these people have reported that,
you know, that they've been harassed at
work.
>> No, they haven't. That's a [__] lie.
He knows it.
>> Been called crazy. Diamond has a family.
I'm sure Jay- Sock has a family. Quan
has a family. He stalks both of them.
I'm sure Wicked Supreme has a family.
And any internet community is going to
have crazy [__] people in it, right?
It's some of these people have reported
that, you know, that they've been
harassed at work.
>> No, they haven't. That's a [__] lie.
You know,
>> hold up. Logically, I believe Dan could
correct me. Dan Saltman's been harassed
at work. I know he's retired, but people
have gone out of his way to [__] with
his businesses. I think they've gone out
of his way to [__] with his family. So
why is this true for Dan and Mutton, but
it's not potentially true for Jtock or
Queman? I don't understand the rationale
behind this. So I would need evidence or
Wicked Supreme. Uh what is the evidence
that none of these people
have experienced harassment at work? I'd
love I'd love to know how you know
that's a lie
>> because Destiny's the biggest victim in
the whole wide world and nothing
anywhere near as bad could ever happen
to anyone else.
>> I do need to run for like
>> you can go, man. I I appreciate you
coming on and yapping. If there's like
another important point that you want to
make, you're welcome back on, but I'm
going to watch this to catch you in your
lie.
>> If they have any evidence, I encourage
them to bring it up while I'm gone so I
can't defend myself and I'll be back in
like 20 30 minutes and I can hop back on
if you want me to to answer for it.
Sounds good. All right, we're we're
going to watch this clip and catch you
in a lie. I'll see you later. All right,
let's go.
>> Knows it.
>> Employees have been called. Their family
members have been called. They've been
tracked down on
>> This has all happened to me, by the way,
and is still happening to me, by the
way. But, okay.
>> Facebook and [__] with their friends
like in Destiny by encouraging his
community to target and attack those
people in the real world has has made
all that happen. Dude, it's literally
crazy that
I'm still in the in the mythos as like
one of one of the top Destiny Alogs when
I literally barely covered him for ages
until this [__] popped off again. I've
been like focused on Ethan Klein,
Nicholas Dioro, Tech Tone, Smash JT,
stuff like that. That's what I've been
focused on for like months. It's crazy,
man.
>> He's encouraged this to happen. And he's
even complained that this community
hasn't gone further. So I don't
understand why would why would say he's
like somehow drawn some clear line
around family members. He he just
hasn't. He he said anybody connected to
these people is fair game.
>> Anybody connected to these people like
the people that are actively involved in
these servers that are harassing every
single person not their [__]
children.
>> You don't get to draw that line. You
don't get to draw that line.
>> You promised Katie Price today instead
we get this I don't even know what
you're going up with Katy Price. Okay. I
I never promised Katie Price. I've got
no idea what you're referring to. If you
find me, which is very easy, I'm easy to
find. That's a deep cut clip. But if you
find me, you find everybody around me.
So saying, "Oh yeah, we just have this
like moral line where we only find the
people criticizing us, but we don't find
their extended family members." That's
not up to you. That's obviously not up
to you. I don't even know why we would
pretend that's up to you. We're we're
we're just pretending like every single
[__] DGER is the exact has the exact
same morality. We're just pretending
that they're like lock step soldiers
with an escalation of force and rules of
engagement. That's not how anything
works.
>> Well, that's it's you're aren't you like
making the same point? It's just like,
well, if you're going to be like
involved in
>> there's like 30 seconds left
>> these like doxing wars or anything like
that, then you're like you're fair game
as well. Like
>> correct. If you if you engage in doxing,
you can be doxed. Even if you're not
engaged in doxing, you're likely to get
doxed. No,
>> it's the same thing.
>> No, my position is that if if this is
the the world he's creating,
>> like wait,
>> the world he's creating.
>> Also, his channel have the strongest
spine. Is that true?
>> DGD doesn't do stupid [__]
>> That's true.
>> You've never done stupid [__] in your
entire [__] life. That's a bold
[__] stance to take. You think you're
batting a thousand? That's impressive.
delusional but impressive
>> into they're doing the child adult thing
again as well, right? Where they have no
choice but to react this way. Maybe
they're just going to dox my child and
his mom and that's all they can do, but
like all of the agencies somehow on my
end. Keep in mind also that this is this
whole thing is a one-sided obsession.
The microsecond these people stop
obsessively talking about me, like it's
done. I don't care like what like I'm
not going to spend all
>> that's the part that I'll It's like
talking about you. Why does have to stop
talking about you? That's insane and
[__] People have to stop talking
about you. If you want to go after
people who are actually engaging in
doxing, in swatting, in actions that are
clearly over the line, that makes total
sense. But that's not the case, is it?
He just wants to go off people talking
about him. Agree with that's the part
I'll agree with. Do you have any
evidence? Where where's your evidence
that DG did any doxing? Didn't Destiny
himself dox Jason
>> and they spam [__] all over Twitter all
day. Again, not all DJs, not all DJs.
You're not responsible for everything
just because you're there. But there is
a huge problem with them. Well, not even
a problem. You know, it's intended. They
spam doxes. Doc, didn't Destiny himself
dox esports Batman? What do you mean DGG
hasn't doxed anyone? If I just called
Destiny right now and I said, "Hey, did
you dox esports Batman?" And he says,
"Yes." What's your follow-up argument?
What's
>> not all DJs, but always a DJ?
>> Your source? What? My source is destiny.
What? What are you talking about? If I
ask the head of a community if he's
docked someone and he's done too
encouraged the doxing of other people
that you get it, man. Anyway, basically
the point is Dooby didn't say anything
actually like crazy. He didn't say that
it was good. He actually said explicitly
the opposite. It wasn't good. So he goes
for a bit. Um he's gone for a bit and
then he comes back on. He argues with
some Jenny and then Destiny comes on. So
I guess we'll watch from here.
>> That's going
on Steven Benell. Fel's my uh my chief
mod. But I'm also not going to
>> treat
>> infiltrating an Adam Waffen group and uh
being Adam Waffen as the same thing. I
think that's crazy pants. Uh, we did
just call Destiny. We didn't uh he
didn't pick up. Hello.
>> Well, hey, what's up, buddy?
>> Hey,
>> what's up?
>> Just milking the content. How you doing?
>> Doing great. Um, what are we talking
about in here today?
>> Yeah, let me uh let me show you.
>> Well, this is this is, I think, actually
incredibly pertinent to the
conversation.
>> So, let me go ahead and pull this up
here. Let me go ahead and share it with
you guys. So,
>> is my mic bad? I have a SH mic, but I'm
I don't want to use it cuz I'm lazy. I
can do it if you guys want me to. I
don't really give a [__]
>> To do what?
>> I'm asking if my mic is bad. So, I have
like a
>> Sounds like a [__] Blue Yeti. No
problems on my end. So,
>> uh what Destiny, what I started this
morning stream with is uh the reasonable
ask that I heard you articulate that I'm
okay with is do not allow snarkers into
your community to end.
>> You know, Destin's always hated Connor.
I I don't know if that's true, but there
is a moment in this where he does just
start like going crazy and being like,
"We're never friends." Basically
>> talks [__] about me or I will no longer
associate fraternized debate or talk
with you. Uh which I think that's
reasonable because we haven't done that.
Uh we we don't have six-hour
anti- Destiny hate rallies in our VC or
text thing. And so if you prohibited
from that
>> Wait a second. Can I ask a quick
question on this just to check?
>> Absolutely. Go ahead.
>> And I, you know, I'm asking from a total
place of ignorance. So, if I were to go
around and ask, there has not a single
time in the past 6 months been a one
plus hour voice call with Dubian here
talking about how I'm a pedophile or
anything. That would be true.
>> I would have to actually I don't think
I've ever called you a pedophile. Wait,
no. I think I did once as a meme, but I
think
>> shut the [__] up. You shut the
>> So, I haven't heard Doobie argue that
Destiny's a pedophile. I haven't heard
that. They can correct me if I'm wrong,
but I don't think we've ever he
literally doesn't give a [__] He
literally doesn't give a [__] what
anyone's saying. Doesn't give a [__]
what the individual argument is.
Literally, the only goal is to
intimidate people. Cause a chilling
effect so the people stop talking about
him. That's all he wants. He doesn't
give a [__] what Doobie's actually said
or what Dooby's actually done. It's It's
literally all just built as a narrative
to try and get people to stop talking
about him.
>> Had the conversation. Let's try to play
nice just so we can get through the
substance and then if we want to be mean
after the substance then we can be mean
after the substance. Um to my to my
>> Has ever Has Dub ever receded in here at
all?
>> Uh I think he's VC in here.
>> Yeah, a few times.
>> And I've never been a subject of that
conversation. If I were to run around
and ask people that's never I've never
been a thing that he's been here. Nobody
has ever been in here for instance and
I've been brought up and then somebody's
like we need to get Dy here to talk
about death. I'm not asking you. You're
a self
right now. I don't No, I don't care.
>> I don't care what you say to me. I'm
asking you, Connor.
>> If I were to ask if I were to ask your
server, if I were to your server,
>> he just goes to me. You're a self
admitted pedophile. Nice one, man. Yeah,
I'm sure. Sure. I I believe you, man.
Die is a self admitted pedophile. Cuz uh
source, you just said it. Awesome stuff,
bro.
>> None of these people would say, "Oh, no,
no, no. We've never heard somebody say,
"Quick, grab Dubbie." Destiny is the
topic of the conversation for Dubbie to
come in and do all of the ordinary
smears. Right.
>> I would I would I would appreciate 30
seconds to answer. To my knowledge, the
answer is no. The people that I would
ask if this had ever happened in the
past 6 months are Tae, uh, who's my
former editor and former chief mod,
Fellrrunner, who's my current chief mod,
and I would ask them if they take out of
context. They may not have seen it.
Doobie spoke about reporting stuff to
the FBI and the the NCMEC
while he was the owner of the politics
Discord. Um, obviously it's a massive
Discord. It's the polit
discord.gg/politics.
Literally the politics discord was
massive. And I'm sure there were lots of
underage people in there during co. I'm
sure he saw a lot of [__] up stuff. If
you reported to the FBI, you hand it all
off. You might be putting yourself at
some liability, but you really got to
shame someone for doing the right thing.
It's just kind of crazy seen anything
like that.
>> Can you drag one of them in here and ask
him?
>> Yeah, sure. Uh Fel was on here 30
seconds ago. Um do you hold on real
quick? Um before I create like another
chat, I suppose. Um I just want to ask a
quick question. Um Destiny, do you have
anything that you want to say to Dubbie
or you want uh feedback from Dubbie on?
And Dubbie, do you have anything that
you want to say to Destiny or give him
feedback on? Because if you guys don't
have
>> Why would I have a mutual one-on-one
that Duby's goal is to destroy my life,
Connor? You're [__] [__] That
was the dumbest question you've ever
asked in your entire entire life.
>> True.
>> True. Do you have anything that you want
to talk to him about? Yes or no?
>> Well, I mean, we could do I mean, we
could run this we could run this one
thing. Conor, did you do you find his
arguments for why uh it's acceptable to
dox my kid and his mom who live in a
separate state from me? Do you find
those arguments compelling? as a
description.
Yes.
>> So you think that if you dox a person
then it is the equivalent to dox the
other person's every single unrelated
family member because the one person who
got doxed might have a family member
that lives with them.
>> Yeah, sure. Let me go ahead and ask you
a question. I don't need anything else.
I just wanted to hear that. I just want
to hear that. That's okay. We don't have
>> Can I kick you so Destiny and I can just
hash this?
>> No, no, no, no. I don't Connor, I'm not
gonna have that conversation with you. I
don't give a [__] honestly. Um, the
second question is
>> I give a [__] The second the second
question
>> I give a [__] because I think hold on
hold on. If we are I know the
>> um I don't know if he's the only one,
Nathan, but I take your point.
>> I know the thumbnail was a meme, but I I
think that this situation is actually
quite serious and you are thinking about
like complete disassociation from me and
Wick. So,
>> it's not serious. This is not a serious
conversation and I'm not I won't
understand. I'll just hang out. I'm
sorry. I'm being honest. Like that's
that opinion is so immediately stupid.
I'm not even gonna pretend to have a
conversation with you unless um remove
all the financial
stupid [__] opinion. No, no, no,
wait. Um, hold on. Wait. There were cuz
there were like two other things related
to Oh, [__]
>> No, you Wait, wait, wait. If you're just
let
you just let this guy talk un
unchallenged for four [__] hours.
Apparently, you're doing [__] the
same racist memes against my community
and now he gets to leave right away
because you
>> dude. So, obviously, we've missed a lot
of it, but Connor was saying some funny
stuff, calling him [__] cultists,
sick of fans, saying maybe there are
maybe there are some Indians in this
community. You guys seem to be
struggling with English. He was saying
some quite funny stuff. Now, I I feel
like I am painting a target on Connor's
back by even acknowledging that some of
the stuff he said was funny cuz they
they literally this drives them [__]
insane for some reason. Like the jokes
about DG and DJ just drive him [__]
insane. It's like, "Oh, you're a bunch
of Indians and this guy's going [__]
crazy about it. I It's really quite
baffling. It's just like something I
just never expected.
>> You want me to call him back? I'll
literally call him back. But I'll tell
you what I'm not going to do. I'll I'll
literally call him back in the next 30
seconds. I'll bring Fel on in order to
ask the exact questions what you want to
ask. But what I'm not going to do, and
I'll tell you right now, is I'm not
going to have you say that after you and
I have had a five going on six-year
relationship that you get to deem a
topic undeserving of your time,
attention, or conversation.
>> Dude,
>> that's not happening.
So, so if you want to have a
conversation about whether or not doxing
an individual is equivalent to doxing
their family, we can have that
conversation. If you want to talk to
Duby, we can talk to Doobie.
>> Do it. Do it real quick. Do it. Run it
down. Go ahead.
>> So, okay. So, if I get doxed, my name,
phone number, and address are located.
How hard do you think it is to find my
extended family members?
>> What? I don't know. Depends on where.
>> So, dude, it's just so [__] stupid.
I'm I'm glad people can just see how
[__] [__] and slippery this guy
is. It's l It's just dishonest. It is
just like he just tries to lie basically
to get through conversation. I don't
know. I don't know. But you do know. You
do know. You know, it's very easy. It's
obviously very easy. But you you just
want to lie to win because you're a
dishonest [__] loser.
>> They live could be pretty easy.
>> [__] It's in it's sometimes it's as
easy as a white pages or yellow pages
Google search. So now I have to wonder
whether or not you're because you didn't
even want to talk about this topic. Now
that we're talking about it and I ask
you a pretty simple and direct question,
you're saying I don't know. I think you
know
>> the problem. No, no. The problem Connor,
the reason why this is the most
important topic in the world is because
you're talking about using theoretical
collateral damage to make a direct
target of somebody else's family member.
Do you know if any of the people that
I've even have family members that live
with them or even have children at all?
>> No, I don't. BUT AT THE SAME TIME, I
THINK it's a logical inference.
>> HOLD ON. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. But
Doobie is running around here dozens of
times making these arguments in these
weird [__] whatever the [__] 6 hour
VCs on all these servers arguing that my
kid and his mom,
>> Dude, people are talking about me in
Discord servers. People I can't believe
it. People are talking about me in
Discord servers. I cannot [__]
believe it. I
>> don't. But at the same time, I think
it's a LOGICAL INFERENCE.
>> HOLD ON. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. But
Doobie is running around here. dozens of
times making these arguments in these
weird [__] whatever the [__] six-hour
VCs on all these servers arguing that my
kid and his mom are fair gamma. You
[__] crazy cotter.
>> Sure. Let's go ahead and address that.
So, let's say hypothetically. Well, Dub
is actually No, no, we don't even have
to treat it as a hypothetical. We could
treat this as a real thing.
>> Let's talk about There you go. Yes.
>> Yeah. Let's talk about real things. So,
Dubbie does have a family.
>> Have you called for his docs in the
past?
>> So, you hear that? He goes, "I haven't
doxed Doobie." He knows that he said to
Connor<unk>'s face that Doobie should be
doxed. The question being asked is
obvious. The point being made is
obvious, but he chooses to just play
[__] stupid. And people people defend
this. People defend this still. People
say, "Oh, how could God possibly betray
his friend like this? I cannot believe
that he would betray Steven." That's
what that's what they're typing. That's
what they're typing. Excuse me. TUBBY
HAS NOT BEEN DODGED. Have you called for
his docs in the past? I'm pretty sure we
had a conversation about it in person.
>> I've tried to find it. Yeah. But I don't
have it.
>> Okay. So, if you had found it, would you
have published it?
>> Almost certainly. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Absolutely.
>> He has a family. So, his argument is you
don't know what's going on in people's
lives and when you expose their PII.
>> Yeah. Connor just lost a thousand is at
Connor just lost a thousand is at today.
Connor minus 10,000 is at. don't know if
most of the time it's going to be fine,
but you don't know whether or not you're
going to put them in direct harm.
Correct.
>> I mean, that's kind of the point of
doxy. Yeah.
>> Right. So, if Dubie was We're not even
engaging in hypotheticals. We're
engaging in a real example. So, if you
had Doc Doobie, let's say you just found
his PII, you publish it to the internet,
and let's say that he is
>> and then Adam off and finds his house
and kills him and kills his [__]
family. Aren't you partially responsible
for that behavior?
>> You possibly could be, but do you think
that [__]
>> Let me let me ask you a question. This
is what we're talking about. You are
Conor, you don't have to talk to me
about this because this has been my life
for the last year. You [__] [__]
Okay, so hold on. So, shut the [__] up.
Let's say that I were to find [__]
Doobie's information and then I find the
information of his kid and I started
posting his kids docks. Do you think
that's the same thing?
>> No.
>> Thank you. Then you agree with me. Then
move on to another topic because this is
[__] [__] No, I won't because
it's quite clear. So, let's say let's
say that you had posted his PII and then
he'd gotten swatted and his dogs had
gotten shot or his kids had gotten
injured in the thing. You're partially
responsible. Yeah.
>> Sure.
>> And then inversely,
it's still not Conor. Conor, it's still
not the same as posting his children's
box.
>> Wow. That was the argument being made,
wasn't it, guys? You remember when
Connor said that, didn't you? When he
said it was the same thing. That was the
argument being made, right? It's just so
[__] lame. It's so [__] lame. It's
not good debating. He is just spazzing.
He's just spazzing and he just stays on
the attack, keeps making accusations,
keeps deflecting and that's his only
strategy. That is his only strategy.
>> I don't think that's even the argument
that he made.
>> That is the argument. He's saying that
my it is okay to a log by minor child
and that it would be fine to post my
kids. Do you have a clip or do you have
somebody that could give me that clip?
>> Bring him in here. He'll argue it.
>> So, we just watched a clip that's being
referred to here.
>> Okay, we understand because seriously,
some DG chatters were some of the
dumbest [__] who jumped in.
>> DG chatters or DGs, Connor?
>> Like, dude, he's so [__] hurt, man.
Over this stupid joke. Over this stupid
[__] joke. It's insane. It's just so
crazy. I cannot believe it's under a
skin so [__] bad. I I legit How does
this make someone so angry? How How What
opinion do you have of Indians to where
this makes you so [__] enraged?
>> We understand because seriously, some
DGG chatters were some of the dumbest
[__] who jumped
>> DG Chatters or DG Jeets, Connor.
>> What?
>> DG Chatters or DG Jeets? Connor,
>> I wasn't going to say Jeets. I'm not
anti-Indian.
>> Okay. Butter buttered chicken and
[__] naan bread is [__] fire.
>> We love Connor. Butter chicken and naan
bread. White whitest guy in the world.
Whitest guy in the world.
>> All right, give me a second. GG G. Jesus
Christ. All right, hold up, hold up,
hold up. Uh, let me go into Discord. Let
me make a new one. Destiny,
>> what? What do you mean make a new one?
He can't just join this one again.
>> Uh, Doobie, if you can hear this, can
you join?
>> I mean, non bread and butter chicken are
both really good. It's just hilarious
that that's where he goes. You know,
they are both really good though.
>> Can I click the call button again? And
should I hang up and call again?
>> I'll hang up and call again and see if
that works. One second. Let me go here.
Lost people. I want the convo. I'm not
doing this whole like [__] it's too
sensitive to [__] talk about thing. I
need to [__] go play video games and
[__] jerk off. I'm not doing that.
That's not happening. Uh at here,
rejoin, please. Oh [__] No, I need I
need to make a new one. I I need to make
a new one because I removed him from the
group. All right. Uh let me add Destiny
and create group message and let me call
everybody.
Okay, should be good. All right, Doobie.
So the accusation is that you are saying
that a logging Nathan and doxing Nathan
is green lit through uh Destiny's
behavior. And no offense Destiny, but
I'm just going to say it.
>> Was that on purpose? No. Hello.
>> Destiny, are you with us?
>> I'm here. Dewey, did you say that it was
acceptable to a log my son and use and
save the information until he's an adult
to send it to somebody later on and the
goal of getting him fired from a job or
kicked out of school? No, I said the
opposite.
>> What did you say?
>> Okay, so I'll just lay it out for you,
right? And you can tell me why you
disagree with this.
>> All right, you gota you got to make him
answer faster, bro. I don't because he
he's going to say he has
>> It's literally descriptive versus
prescriptive. Stephen, you used to be
the master [__]
>> Don't tell me to force him to answer the
question quicker and then tell me to
shut the [__] up. That doesn't make
sense.
>> I'm losing my mind. It's all good. Don't
worry. I just woke up. So my
>> You don't have anything else to do,
[__] You going to jerk off, go
bang a Tinder chick?
>> I have a million other things to do. and
jerking off and begging a tit would be
infinitely more entertaining than
listening to the same guy that was
slobbering and crying about food trucks
being hosted by my stream at night make
justifications for why guys who are
spending hours why they duck my [__]
WHY THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED
STEVEN THAT'S A NORMAL OPINION you it's
a
>> brilliant just amazing just [__]
amazing
it's just already peak and it's not even
started it's just already [__] peak
You you just can't you can't beat this.
You really just can't beat this.
>> NORMAL OPINION TO NOT WANT TO HANG OUT
WITH PEDOPHILES.
>> IS IN HERE. I DON'T HANG OUT WITH THESE
PEOPLE. AND DY'S IN HERE BEGGING GIRLS,
>> DUDE. I don't hang out with these
people. Yes, you do. You go on food shop
stream all the [__] time. What do you
mean? Yes, you do.
>> Little girls for their [__] noobs in
DMs.
>> Is this the commentary season finale?
How could it get better? The best is yet
to come. Okay. Like uh what did who was
it that said that? Was it [__] his
name like Sydney something? The Trump
[__] The Trump [__]
>> See, they said to other guys,
[__]
FOR six years.
>> Let him do the next one. You what?
>> You would do the same AS ME FOR SIX
[__] years. Don't tell me you don't
hang out with these [__]
>> That's a lie. Hold on. I'm not a
pedophile. That's a lie. DOOBIE. WHEN DO
I HANG OUT with Doobie?
>> Wait, hold on. To be clear, I'm not a
pedoph.
The entire goddamn panel scene where I
met you, too. By the way,
>> [__] out of here.
>> I'm sorry. Are we saying hang out is
when on panels together? In that case, f
I guess I hang out with Vivian M.
>> Based off of panels for the first three
years of
>> So, so it's just like they are just like
having a breakup. Like it's just like
the gayest [__] in the world. It's just
crazy. Like Connor has met this guy in
real life multiple times.
>> Our friendship, you [__] So
yeah, don't get all [__] dismissive
about the [__]
everything you're saying is the most.
You think that the friendship that we
HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THE SAME.
>> NO, IT'S NOT. YOU'RE JUST [__] PISSED
OFF AND YOU KNOW A BUNCH OF [__] SICK
FANS WILL JERK YOU OFF AND I'M NOT GOING
TO DO IT.
>> SICK OF MY SICK OFFENSE. YOU'RE SO HOW
many do I'm curious?
>> Like he literally can't take it, bro. He
literally can't take it. Connor has just
dealt with hours of sick fans making the
most insane arguments to him and he just
calls out calls it out calls it as he
sees it and that thing is [__]
insane.
>> Dude, if you had to guess how many sides
splinter discords could open, right?
>> Dude, that two doors in one year might
be too much for Connor. Dude, I put such
a funny message in chat, but I think it
hurt Connor's feelings. I said uh he was
like crashing out his chat and I was
like I'd say you're moments away from a
full Benoir but well and it
seemed like I hurt his feelings but I
thought that was really I thought that
was funny. I thought I was like funny
>> right now that are cheering on Conor for
standing up to the evil horrible
terrible destiny. How many you think I
can open up right now?
>> Stand up
[__] [__] You're so [__]
[__]
>> I just I I just can't not say a joke
like If I think of like a [__] up
funny joke like that, I just have to say
it, you know. That's not crazy.
>> Die, go ahead and justify why you can a
log my 15-year-old kid. Go.
>> Yes, please.
>> Okay, so I'll lay it out for you again
like I to Connor. So, there are lots of
crazy people online. When you encourage
doxing,
>> yeah, I like I like editor.
>> I don't know what the [__] who who
you're talking to, right? [__]
lunatic in your community that sees me
and thinks that sees me believes
everything I say about me and thinks
that I'm trying to take you down and
thinks it's justified to attack me
physically to attack my family
physically. There could be people that I
have unrelated uh beef with, right? And
I do uh that might say, "Hey, we have
Dup's address now. Let's go [__] kill
him." So, I'm not saying that you
personally would be uh doxing my
>> You know what triggered this? Go back to
the start of the stream. Go back to the
start of the stream. But you doxing me,
given that I live with my [__] son,
would put my entire [__] family at
risk. That is just a reality. I'm not
saying it's a good thing. I don't accept
it. I would not do that to you or your
son ever. I would never support that
ever. What I'm telling you is just you
need to stop creating this environment
where that's going to be normalized.
>> Just curious, Connor, did you hear an
explanation there or is that
>> I did and I've been linked clips where
people have said his description like
what he's saying right now is a lie. And
then when I get linked the clips, he's
saying the exact same thing. So what he
said,
>> if you want to show THEM BEING A LIAR,
give me the clip. I would love it.
>> What he has what he has said is that
right now based on the rules that I've
created, a logging my child would be
fair game. Right, Dub?
>> Correct. Because you put his child at
risk.
>> Okay. So the more these are morally
equivalent actions in your eyes is
stalking a 15-year-old child until
they're 18 to turn in whatever you
manage to collect to their future
employer. Whatever that is the morally
equivalent action to posting the name
and address of somebody and them maybe
having family members that live with
them. These are two things are morally
equivalent to you.
>> If you are risking his child of
homicide, why wouldn't he be allowed to
a log and dox your child?
>> Okay. So then just TO BE CLEAR,
I AGREE WITH YOU. I agree with you. No.
No. Okay. I agree with you. It's fair
game right now. If I find the docks of
any of Doobie's family members, it's
fair game for me to post them, right?
>> Has he doxed you?
>> No, but he's made the argument that it's
fair game to go after my family, so I
should be able to descriptive or
prescriptive.
>> I'm being descriptive. I'm just saying.
Yeah, it would be right. Like he
wouldn't be able to complain about it.
>> Descriptively,
he he can't even track the conversation.
He was asking whether the statement in
that hypothetical by Doobie was
descriptive or prescriptive. Well, not
even hypothetical whether whether you be
state was descript or prescript. He just
tries to flip it. Tries to flip it
immediately because it's easier to argue
that way.
>> No, I'm just describing.
>> I know you know this, which is why this
conversation is so frustrating.
>> If I'm describing because it's almost
like he's not being honest with you,
Connor. It's almost like he's like, you
know, like a total piece of [__] He's
not being honest with you
>> because you No, no. You've talked about
tit for tat. You've talked about eye for
an eye.
>> Conor, I'm describing right now. Connor,
I'm only describing.
>> Excuse me. I'm only describing. I didn't
say I would do it. I didn't say I should
do it. I'm just saying that if I did, he
wouldn't be able to complain about it.
>> You don't think that's a substantive
difference?
>> I never said I should do it. I'm just
saying he wouldn't be able to complain
about it. Like, I could do it and I
would have justification for it, but
that's it. I'm not saying I should.
>> So, hold on. Hold on. Let's
>> just agree. Stop talking.
>> Oh my god.
>> So, if D,
>> dude, it's so It's like so embarrassing.
He behaves like a [__] child. Legit
behaves like a [__] child. just
totally spurs out, cast apersions, tries
to flip the conversation around. And
Connor says, "I'm just gonna get my
point out." And he's like, "Oh my god.
Oh my god. You really want to talk in
this conversation? You really want to
talk in?" Yeah. Yeah. Conor is just
going to make his point. So just shut up
for a second. Doxed you first and he put
your child at risk based off of an eye
for an eye morality. You would be
entitled to doxing his family and
putting his family at risk. That's
descriptively true. Where
>> the description that Doobie was making,
the description that Dubie was making
was that some crazy person might find a
doc and do something horrible to his
family and blah blah blah blah blah. My
argument would be some crazy person, and
by crazy person, I mean the people that
are already stalking, doxing, harassing
me, and calling swats on my family
members. They might see Dubbiey's
argument and go, "Oh, Duby's actually
spitting fire here. We should actually
try to swat and murder his [__]
family." I have way more evidence on my
side for this.
Oh, you're [__] Okay, that's fine.
Then what's the next argument about
that? Dubie is making those arguments in
Discord.
>> Describe something inaccurately, declare
victory, and walk away.
>> Well, that's where you're wrong, Connor.
Cuz that's exactly what he does.
>> That's not how you What am I describing?
Interactive. Doobie is making a
description. You're justified. Move on
because you cannot
>> every [__] time at this point. That
is just what he does.
>> Hold on. Let me answer this directly.
>> Answer this directly. I want you to
answer this directly.
>> Yeah. If if Dubbie doxed you and put
your child at risk, would you not be
descriptively entitled to doxing him and
putting his children at risk?
>> The goal of dox him without putting
their children. If that happens, it's
collateral. If somebody do something, I
think you're going to dox them. Yeah.
Sure.
>> Don't Okay, so the answer is yes.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So 6 months to a year ago, you
were calling for Doobie to be doxed. He
has children and so you put his family
at risk. So descriptively, he's saying
you are creating a world in which it is
okay for him to do the same to you, but
he's not going to.
>> He doesn't have to. He's out here in
Discords doing the equivalent of calling
for it. When you're out here saying
Destiny wouldn't be able to complain if
people doxed his whole family because
he's created the world for it and that's
the world we live in now. That's the
argument.
>> I'm sorry. I literally I can't do the
whole recap. Okay guys, I'm keep saying
if you want to get the recap, go back to
the start of the stream. Destiny's mad
as [__] Okay, that's all that's all I
can
>> he's making. If he's going to say that
there's a chance that a crazy person in
my community, of which this has never
happened by the way, is going to go and
find his family members and cause damage
to his family. Why is it not the same on
his side when people have done this to
my family? Okay. So, hold on. Let's go
ahead and follow that. So, based off of
that, you're saying that he's creating
the stochastic permission structure
through which you can be doxed and
harassed. And since you're being doxed
and harassed, you have the right to dox
him.
>> No, hold on. I don't care about me being
doxed as you're proving here. I'm barely
[__] human you guys anyways. I don't
care about me. What I'm saying
>> you're human to me, you [__] You're
[__]
>> What I'm saying is that your friends
don't just let you do whatever the [__]
you want. They call you out when you're
doing something stupid.
>> Call me out. Oh my god, you guys are so
entitled. It actually It drives me
[__] insane. But that's fine,
>> dude. How [__] crazy is that mask
slip? How [__] insane is that mask
slip, dude? Literally, he feels like
they should be subservient to him. He
feels like Connor should be subservient,
that Connor is below him. What do you
mean hold me accountable? What do you
mean call me out? How [__] dare you?
It's It's just crazy.
>> I'm sorry. my question.
>> I'm sorry. I think you're doing
something cringe and gay and I'm I'm I'm
entitled because I'm saying you're doing
something cringe and gay.
>> Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Oh, [__] you. So, you do want to tongue
up your ass.
>> So, my Yeah. Yeah, dude. That's me. You
totally figured it out, bro. Um not not
not the guy that's in here donating what
was it? $10,000 to streamers for the
past 18 months to try to hold on [__]
friendships so they can go into Discords
and TALK ABOUT ME. NON [__] STOP FOR
A YEAR. NOT THAT GUY. I'm the one who
wants the special treatment. Wasn't your
mod just in here earlier telling you
that people like Doobie were a [__]
cancer? Maybe he wants to tongue up his
ass, too. Who's that [__] stuck up
loser? What was his name? Fels. What'
you call him?
>> Don't be mean to Fel Runner. Fellrunner
likes you.
>> I just want to know who else wants to
tongue up their ass, but you don't want
people that are gossiping, calling them
pedophiles and and taking part actively
in communities that have been doxy,
swatting, making bomb threats to his
[__] family for the past two years. I
don't know who else is like a spoiled
[__] like that.
>> Okay.
>> My Okay, so my simple question [__]
>> Go ahead. My my simple question is is
how is Doobie running around all these
VCs making the argument that well
according to Destiny it should be okay
to a log his child and his family
members and dox them. How is that not
also creating an environment where
crazies can you know find or think
>> this is the sort of evil guys like I
said evil stuff happening in that snark
server recently quite evil stuff coming
out of that snark server
>> that they have some justification of
doing this because
in their entirety immediately after he
gets done saying that in a descriptive
nature he says I wish everybody would
stop doing this [__] so we could return
to what Twitch and YouTube politics was
2 years ago where doxing was not
something that we would tolerate. It was
a taboo.
>> Which side do you think contributes to
it, Connor?
>> Which side do I think contributes to the
normalization of doxing and harassment?
>> Let me let me ask you this question. If
I were to drop all of my aggression
towards this these communities, do you
think that they would still continue to
dox, swat, harass, inject themselves
into my life in as many ways as
possible? Dude, him being aggressive
isn't stopping it either because he's
not even targeting the people that are
doing it. I'm not out of doxing. I'm not
out of swatting. I'm out of harassing
and I tell other people not to and I
enforce that in my community. But when
he does it, other actors get emboldened
to retaliate. You can just you can just
see that. You can just see that when he
go starts going crazy, the crazies that
already hate him on the periphery, they
activate. And and what can anyone else
do about that? What can I do about that?
Nothing. It's not me doing it. It's not
my community doing it. I can't do [__]
about it. When if anything like that
ever happens, I deal with it. So, what
the [__] can be done?
>> I think yes. Okay. And if they were to
stop, do you think
>> I know what can be done? He just wants
people to stop talking about him, stop
covering him. That's that's what's
really happening.
>> That I would be for months, years after
be like, "Guys, we still got to go after
Dooby. We got to get this guy. We got to
find Do you think that I would continue
on?" No. if they were to stop. Okay. So,
it's them. I don't know why you're
making this a both sides thing. It's
them. You understand?
>> Because I can articulate this because
you are engaged in total warfare. You
are going scorched earth. If we were to
analogize this to Vietnam, you are
dropping [__] napom. You're burning
thatched houses. You're executing
civilians who are sympathetic to the
[__] Viet.
>> Hold on. What is the most scorched earth
thing that I've done?
>> Doxing sports Batman and
>> I wish I lived I wish I lived and
calling for myself
>> I wish I lived in a world where that was
like the scorched earth because holy
[__] that sounds like heaven to me
>> I can't even believe I I'm not talking
about morally justified. I'm just saying
that your portrayal of this is scorched
earth when I have a community of people
who are weaponizing mentally ill women
to try to destroy my [__] life in
court when I've got people calling bomb
threats in on
>> weaponizing mentally ill women to
destroy his life in court. Hold on to
that thought first of all guys. Hold on
to that thought. So Desi acknowledges a
lot of the women he sleeps with are
mentally ill. Now let's just address
that as it stands though. How the [__]
is anyone doing that? You wronged a
woman in a way that is potentially
actionable and she's suing you. And and
even if people are giving her
information to assist her in that,
what's the problem with that? Seriously,
explain that. That's not someone doing
something wrong to you. If there is an
actionable suit against you and someone
say JTalk has relevant information and
passes it along to Pixie, what's the
problem? Please explain the wrong there.
>> On my apartment, my parents apartment.
You're like the worst THING EVER.
DESTINY, YOU'RE GOING SCORCHED EARTH CUZ
YOU DOXED A FEW OF THE MOST ACTIVE
MEMBERS OF THESE COMMUNITIES. DESTINY,
THAT'S [__] SCORCHING. BY THE WAY,
JUST CURIOUS, what has happened to any
of these people? Has anything have
anybody been swatted? Has anybody shown
up any of their places work? Has anybody
sued any of these people? Has anything
happened to any of these people at all?
>> I'll ask. Was it moral or just to do
what you did?
>> You pressed based off how crazy his lisp
is.
>> Thank you for the $5. Huge appreciate.
Thank you.
>> So, yeah. Self-defense and
accountability.
>> Wait, wait. doesn't like the idea. If
doesn't like the idea doesn't like the
idea that him running around saying
insane [__] about me 24/7 all this time.
If he thinks that his real life name
being attached to that would make him
act significantly different, maybe he
should reconsider the things that he
says or does. The reason why when I post
stuff, I post it on my name in my chat
under my ACCOUNT IS BECAUSE I WILL TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR the things that I
say. Easy. Full stop. You know my full
name. You know my [__]
>> See, this is just like total delusional
cube because he will never accept
consequence and he will always lie about
details to try and exonerate himself. So
you you can say, "Oh, I do it under my
account. I take accountability." No, you
lie to try and exonerate yourself and
you refuse any consequence. So no,
that's not taking accountability, you
[__] idiot.
>> [__] address because Pixie loves to
[__] come all over it every two weeks
at a court filing. So if YOU WANT TO
TALK TO ME OR DO ANYTHING TO ME, YOU CAN
SHOW TO MY [__] APARTMENT. LORD
DELOOD gave you the [__] FLOOR TO
TAKE THE elevator up on. Meanwhile,
Doobie wants to run around and talk the
weirdest [__] pedto [__] about me
24/7 while he's jerking off over his
mountains of child porn that he claims
he's hoarding for the FBI. He wants to
talk to me every single day. And he's
like, "Well, I think that I should be
able to do this anonymously and nobody
should have." And if people even knew my
name, they would come to my family.
Maybe that's an indictment on his
behavior more than mine.
>> Okay, so to be So let let's go for
wicked. So let's ignore Doobie for a
second. Esports Batman gave legal
consultation to Jtock, one of your
principled haters in the nexus of your
whatever you want to call it, your f
your [__] haters, your stalkers. So
in your mind, doxing him was justified.
When you say legal console, what do you
mean?
>> Was wasn't uh his crime or alleged crime
giving legalistic feedback to Jtock in
reference to your court case?
>> Wow. Terrible. Esports Batman
credentials himself as a lawyer and is
literally creating a permission
structure in their discord for a way
through which they can misinterpret or
whatever interpret however you want to
call it all every [__] court filing I
have. He's like their he's like their on
call legal guy. Anytime you hear Dubbie
or any other [__] [__] be like oh
lawyers who told me this they're talking
about esports Batman. I think that if
you're going to put your CREDENTIALS OUT
THERE, IF YOU'RE PUTTING IF you're put
if somebody thinks that I think that
Kofka coming on as the legal person on
Dusty Stream and this is who he is or
whatever. I mean, yeah. I mean, I think
that it's I think it's fair. There's a
reason why, by the way, most leaguers
most lawyers are really reluctant to
show up and like give a whole bunch of
legal advice or go give a whole bunch of
stuff on [__] streams or YouTubes
because when you credential yourself,
that's kind of a thing. But I will say
there is a substantial difference
between Kafka uh coming on and talking
about like random [__] Supreme Court
rulings and esports Batman being the
personal on call snarker lawyer to give
all the [__] interpretations of all
the legal [__] and the same servers
where people are reaching out to and
harassing witnesses in my case are
substantially different. I know you're
going to treat them as
>> I'm going I'm going someplace. So So HFA
has talked about your court case on
stream, right?
>> Sure.
>> Okay. So since he's giving you feedback
in reference to your course,
>> it's the exact same Connor. Yes, you're
a genius. Yes. So he should he should be
doxed, right? Because he's enabling the
infinite rate machine.
>> If I found out that Kofkco was in a
server where they were trying to reach
out to
>> I don't want you to change it. I want
you to answer the question.
>> I'm not changing. I'm making it one to
one. I'm not watering it down like your
dumb ass just did. If Kofkco was in a
Discord server where people were
reaching out to and harassing uh family
and friends of of J
>> No, I'm not going to give you a general
rule. Actually, I'm going to drill down
into this one specific situation and try
and intuition pump it as hard as
possible so that you're just immediately
convinced or that it feels optically bad
to to defend against it. Okay, nice one,
[__] No one sees what you're doing
here. Literally, we're I I'm [__] 12
years old and Indian and have no idea
what you're doing here. They stalk or
try to harass witnesses, bring the case
and Kofka's in the back there say like,
"Oh, look at these legal fun. Yeah, I
think you know this is actually fine and
I think actually this is totally
purposeful." Blah, blah, blah. And
[__] justical docs Kafka be like,
"Oh, [__] it, Kafka. What the [__] do
YOU THINK WOULD HAPPEN, [__] I'M THE
KING OF [__] AROUND and find out. When
the [__] have I ever looked at a
situation like that and be like, "Wow, I
can't believe this guy did this thing."
>> The king of [__] around and find out
until you're getting sued for sharing
non-conensual images and videos. [__]
idiot. Like, what the [__] are you
talking about?
>> [__] [__] Of course, I would
understand it. But for you to compare
Kafka coming onto my public stream and
like talking sometimes and now more
towards the end of the beginning about
court filings, you just say that that's
the same as esports Batman who exists at
a server where they are reaching out to
and harassing [__] witnesses in my
case and he's sitting there creating the
permission structure for it by
credentiing himself as a lawyer and then
giving [__] feedback on every
[__] court filing. You're [__]
[__] But I know in your mind you're
going to find a way to make that
equivalent. That's fine.
>> Uh well, okay. So, so hold on. So,
you've acknowledged descriptively while
adding 10,000 [__] qualifiers that
CFKA is coming on in order to
>> Wait, hold on. Wait, real quick. Real
quick, you can acknowledge just real
quick. The all the 10,000 [__]
qualifiers added, those are all the ones
that apply to esports Batman, right?
>> That Okay.
>> that he lives in a Discord server WHERE
PEOPLE ARE HARASSING WITNESSES.
>> Recite to me the 600 different
qualifiers I just added to this. So, you
can answer this question honestly. in my
case and then he's giving legal cyber
there, right? Yes. Okay. I I don't want
to go down this because then I have to
bring
>> Can you believe he was in a Discord with
someone that I feel did something wrong?
Uh, yep. No one cares, man. Literally,
no one gives a [__] The idea that you
should be held accountable for every
user in a Discord server you participate
in is beyond [__] And again,
Destiny knows this. Let's just sneak
this in quickly. Destiny knows this is a
[__] standard,
>> right?
>> Shut the [__] up, you stupid.
>> I can't really
>> on website see accusations were like,
"Wow, we've spent
>> [__] me. Hold on. Where is it?"
>> Really comment on that. I do know that.
Um I mean I I feel like it's kind of
hypocritical to be um blaming him for
being part of a forum, right?
>> Oh, shut the [__] up, you stupid [__]
really blaming him for being part of a
threat that is engaged in so much
harassment that my [__] mother's
address was leaked and they went after
my family. How [__] discourserained
are you that this is actually something
that you would say?
>> Holy.
>> Uh, so I'm not trying to get mad or
anything like that. Okay.
>> Right. I I've expressed you that I don't
approve of doxing and I don't
>> He's in your chat.
>> Yes.
>> Tell him you don't approve of him being
in Kiwi Farms.
>> He knows that I don't approve of doxing,
but Kiwi Farms is
>> But you're like okay with it. So, but
you're okay with people who engage in
that in your community because he's
there right now. I mean, I don't think
people in my community engage in that.
Nobody in my community is do.
>> Is Flamco not part of your community? Is
he not in your chat? Just like you said,
>> he's a much bigger He has a much bigger
community.
>> You should call her a [__] cut at the
end of this. I don't remember.
>> We had this platforming discussion 5
minutes ago.
>> We had the platforming discussion. He's
in your chat. You're not doing anything.
You don't care. This is just
>> unless unless you have unless you have
screen I'm willing to ban him if you
have screenshots of him posting docs.
But
>> he didn't post docs. He engaged in the
thread. He engaged in a group harassing
>> because
remember when this was a standard, guys?
How is this not just what Destiny is
doing right now? How is Destiny not just
careful in this clip? I challenge any DJ
to explain how this is not perfectly
analogous. How this is not just Destiny
now.
>> He didn't post docks. He engaged in the
thread. He engaged in a group harassing
>> because people just hate stupid that you
can't see that this is the issue. The
issue is that he engaged in a group.
>> So again, just because people hate on
me, right? And that and I can say the
same thing about when people have been
directed hate towards me. I just because
they've engaged in it doesn't mean
they're also responsible for every
single thing that happens as a result of
that hate.
>> He is he's part of that is responsible
directly.
>> Just start playing the piano, Stevie.
>> He directly encouraged it. I've seen the
[__] he said about me. I've seen his
like cozy stream where he uses memes
that use content from the [__]
thread. How is he not culpable here?
>> What kind of content does he use from
the thread?
>> Oh, shut the [__] up. You want me to
like pull up the Nazi site and look over
his memes?
>> I mean, I I don't The reason why I'm
asking is because I don't know. No, I
haven't paid attention to you.
>> You don't know.
>> I came here to talk about you and me,
not about him.
>> This is why I'm mad.
Because you have no morals. You have no
principles. You're willing to just stand
by people who engage in group harassment
on a forum that multiple trans people
have killed themselves.
>> You coordinated group harassment of
plenty of other people.
>> Group harassment. Group harassment. Do
you have anyone who has to lock their
door at night because they're scared
because they get like hate mail directly
to their house?
>> That's not right. I've said that that's
not right. The
>> This is literally It is one to one. It
is one to one. It's [__] insane.
You're too
in your community. Who do you interact
with? Who do you call friends? Because
you're a [__] snake.
>> But I need I need screenshots of him
actually posting.
>> I'll get all of those. He didn't post
the docks. He engaged in group
harassment.
>> If he encouraged if he encouraged
>> he encouraged other people by engaging
in group Do you know what group
harassment is? You have more than two
brain cells. Jesus. Stardust.
>> I know. I understand what group
harassment is. I've had people on Cozy
direct their entire followings to come
hate raid me. So I understand what that
is. But um I I still need to see like
like more than somebody just
participating and being you know towards
somebody, right?
>> In a [__] thread in the same thread.
>> Thank you for the membership. Thank you.
>> That multiple people have killed
themselves over. Are you [__] How
stupid are you? Like
>> how you made a spreadsheet of of content
creators who are all smaller than you
that you wanted to
>> Molina. You get the point here, man.
It's it's just it's totally onetoone.
It's totally analogous. There's
literally no way around it. He's just
totally betrayed all his principles from
backling because he's a [__]
victimizing self victimizing loser.
>> Equivalent. And then you have to tell me
how it's not equivalent.
>> And I just I feel vindicated. I I feel
incredibly vindicated in my uh in my
assessment. I've always said, you know,
the careful [__] is what totally put me
off this guy because he he acted like he
was uh really going to go for it. Go
hell or leather. Try and fix/prevent the
damage Keeles was doing. And then he
backed off because Oh, stop talking
about me. Stop talking about me. And
what do you see? What do you see now? He
never cared about any of it. He never
believed any of it. It was just to get
to stop talking about him.
>> Equivalent.
>> Wouldn't Wouldn't it be attempting to
dox Rose?
>> What?
>> After your homemade pornography I'll
articulate. You said what with
exclamation point and a question mark. I
would like the opportunity to explain.
>> I know. I understand what you're saying.
I just have to catch up. I don't know
how mind raped you are by the [__]
retards in your [__] DMs. Okay. So, I
understand what you're saying now.
>> There's no question [__] DMs.
Every conversation he's doing this now.
Every conversation. No one's DMing, bro.
No one's DMing. I literally I DM' Connor
like what did I DM Connor? I literally
DM'd him. If you want to postpone till
tomorrow, that's fine. And please stop
lumping me in with people who go after
his kid. I don't do that [__] That's
what I said. That's what I said to
Connor in DMs throughout this entire
thing. I don't think anyone else is
DMing Connor as far as I know.
>> YOU ARE FULLY RAPED.
>> WELL, I mean, they could have been. I I
shouldn't mistake anything on that. They
were very well could have been, but
you're saying they're not.
>> You are. Conor, you are fully raped.
Conor, you are. I'm sorry. So, let me
just I can I know exactly what you're
saying. YOU'RE SAYING THAT DOX ROSE,
RIGHT? WHY DID I DOX? WHY DID I WANT TO
FIND OUT WHO ROSE WAS?
>> Because she leaked your homemade
pornography to the internet.
>> Do you think it's fair for people to
want to know who that person is?
>> Yes.
>> Do you think that that is at all?
>> And obviously that requires you putting
out a public bounty to Kiwi Farms to
find her and then free scrolling the
Kiwi Farms post about her on stream,
doesn't it?
Only the best and bravest people ride or
die for DGG. Now, who are they again?
Same people who like Tecton and the
quarter.
>> Thank you for the 50 Swedish growing
there. Huge appreciate it. Just go over.
Thank you.
>> Equivalent to them reaching out and
harassing A PERSON BECAUSE THEY'RE
TRYING TO [__] out as a pedophile in
a [__] case. She doesn't want to be
involved.
>> Okay, hold up hold. We're we're going to
do an experiment in empathy and you need
to slow down a little bit. Okay. So, do
you think that people could earnestly
hate you for the way that you've
conducted yourself on the internet for
the past 3 to 5 years?
>> That has nothing to do with this, and
I'm not answeringly [__] question.
>> 100%.
>> It's so funny, man.
>> What the [__] does that have to do with
what we're talking about here?
>> Because it's the motivations of the
people. It's the motivations of the
people that you're talking about.
>> No, I would say no, Connor. No, there is
no reason. No, give me one.
>> Sorry.
>> Give me one. YOU TELL ME ONE. GIVE ME
ONE [__]
>> DUDE. He's literally about to cry, man.
It's [__] crazy. I just I I have
nothing to say, but it's [__] crazy.
He has lost it. This guy has totally
lost it.
>> What the [__] does that have to do with
what we're talking about here
>> because it's the motivations of the
people. It's the motivations of the
people that you're talking about.
>> No, I would say no, Connor. No, there is
no reason. No. Give me one.
>> Sorry.
>> Give me one. You tell me one. Give me
one.
>> So crazy. Genuinely the worst I have
ever seen this guy. And he's had he's
had some bad [__] moments. This is
the worst I've ever seen this guy.
>> [__] reason.
>> CALL ME A FAT [__] YOU HAVEN'T LIFTED A
WEIGHT IN FIVE GODDAMN YEARS. You piece
of [__] SHUT THE [__] UP. CALL ME
TELLING YOU YOU'RE A FAT [__] IF YOU
CALL ME FAT [__] KILL ME. I wouldn't
be able to withstand the pressure
potter. Tell me right now. What is a VAL
WHAT IS ONE valid reason why these
people could hate me for my behavior the
past 5 years? Tell me.
>> Well, hold on. Do you I'll give you the
general reasons for why people hate you.
I know.
>> Number one. No. No. You ask, I'm going
to answer. You ask, I'm going to answer.
You ask, I'm going to answer. So, how
about how about that time? How about
that time that you posted uh a Minecraft
uh character destroying a holy site in
Islam? Do you think you got a few from
that?
>> I DIDN'T KNOW IT WAS [__] MUSLIM.
THAT WOULD EXPLAIN SO MUCH.
>> NO, NO, DON'T DON'T ISOLATE. Don't
isolate. I'm ask I asked you a question.
Don't isolate.
>> Thank you for the 499, Lil Florida.
Thank you. You appreciate. Thank you.
>> I asked you a question. Do you think
that people could earnestly [__] hate
you and want you dead on the internet?
And then you said no. Zoom out.
>> Zoom out to the every [__] thing. My
bad. Yeah, sure. Go ahead.
>> If you already know your chronology of
sins, then you already know there's
10,000 reasons why people could
earnestly [__] hate you and want you
dead.
>> None of that has anything to do with
this situation at all.
>> So, so hold on. You think JSTock,
Queman, esports Batman, they all hate
you for delusional or non-serious
reasons?
>> Yes.
>> Uh I That's crazy.
>> That's why when I asked you for one, the
only thing you could name was the
[__] Cabba Minecraft [__] because you
know you're come up with a dozen reasons
to hate you OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD.
>> GIVE ME ONE. GIVE ME ONE FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE. GO.
>> YO, thank you for the 50 Swiss Corron.
Huge appreciate. Thank you.
>> [__] use your sexual power and clout
and influence and money in order to rape
mentally [__] women.
>> Give me one example.
>> Anavoreoir.
>> Annavoir reached out to me. ANNAVORE
WANTED TO MEET ME FOR TWO OR THREE
YEARS. Is she more or less [__] than
Cherry?
>> Cherry's also [__] That's not a
good point.
>> Didn't fly her out to Canada?
>> So, this is like a beyond [__]
point. Um, this is really [__]
stupid. It's not just about sleeping
with mentally ill women. Obviously, if
you couldn't sleep, if sleeping with
mentally ill women was rape, consensual
sex would be impossible. Everyone,
please clap. Please clap. Please laugh.
Okay. The point with Anna is that she
had severe OCD specifically focused on
how she was uh perceived online. And
Destiny exploited that deliberately
patri
he exploited that deliberately. And
that's shown in the logs. He says she's
freaking the [__] out about how she's
perceived. And he says, "May maybe I'll
sort that out later, but for now, let's
just keep robbing your legs and feets.
It's just like it's so depraved." And
the guy threatened to revenge porn her
if she leaked sexual details about him,
which meaning leaked sex that showed
they were still having a relationship
while he was smearing her as a stalker
on his stream. That's what he meant by
that. So this guy literally mistreated
this woman in the some of the most just
like [__] depraved ways that you
can online at least, you know, obviously
didn't literally rape her, you know, but
he did treat her in a [__] horrendous
way and utilize his platform, his
audience to do so.
>> Commit her for 3 days, continue to bring
her onto stream to milk her and farm HER
FOR [__] CONTENT TRYING TO [__]
KILL HERSELF. HOLD ON. SO, how the [__]
could there be any hatred of me when I
hooked up with this girl one time, by
the way, when she pursued ME OVER AND
OVER AND OVER and over over again, by
the way, when there's not a single
example of me leveraging more power
dynamics to do anything to her, by the
way,
let's isolate this variable. Let's
isolate this variable. Do you think Do
you think Hold on. Sorry. I want to
isolate this variable because I I think
Steven needs to needs to hear this. It's
crazy that all these people hate him or
at point time friends fans.
>> Or do you not think that people could
rightfully criticize you for repeatedly
engaging with mentally ill women?
Repeatedly engaging with mentally ill
women. If your first go-to example is
Anavoir, I just want to tell you buddy
in the real world. I know you've been
minded by this online [__] Apparently
I'm the only one that's [__] touched
grass before. Nobody would give a [__]
about a 30-year-old woman up with a
32-year-old guy who goes on lying to
talk about him obsessively for the next
[__] year and say, "Wow, that guy is
a I guess a horrible evil [__]
person."
>> So the answer is no. You you actually
you just like like So So you actually
don't think it's a valid criticism to
say Steven has used money, power, clout,
and influence in order to routinely
engage in promiscuous behavior with
mentally ill women.
>> No. If you believe if you Is that you or
mind? Okay, that's fine. Conor,
>> I final
I believe that
I'm asking if you want since I've known
you.
>> You can believe that. That's fine. Are
there any other things you want to go
over?
>> Sorry, I had to grab I had to grab a
drink. Thank you for the 999. Huge
appreciate. Tbo time you had. Huge
appreciate. Thanks so much.
>> This is probably done.
>> Turn this back.
>> Nobody would give a [__] about a
30-year-old woman up with a 32year-old
guy who goes online to talk about him
obsessively for the next [__] year.
If you literally if you showed someone
in the real world all the evidence of
the Anna situation, they would be like,
"Wow, this guy is a total piece of
shit." Anyone would say that. If you
don't think that, it's probably because
you've been sop don't know all the
information because the way you treated
him was [__] absurd.
>> And say, "Wow, that guy is a I guess a
horrible evil [__] person."
>> So the answer is no. You you actually
you just like like so so you actually
don't think it's a valid criticism to
say
>> Stephen has used money power clout and
influence in order to routinely engage
in promiscuous behavior with mentally
ill women.
>> No, if you believe if you believe that
you are mind okay that's fine.
>> I no you think how I treat Anna's bad
you should see how my what my audience
have been doing to mono lizards.
No, no, no. I believe that one
you
>> can believe that. That's fine. Are there
any other things you want to go over?
Cuz this is we're this is probably done.
>> Okay. Well, no. If you if you got to
[__] go, Dude, I'm not doing this
thing. I'm not doing this thing where
you pretend. Yeah. See this? So, it's
[__]
>> So, wait. Hold on. I didn't even get to
talk with me.
>> No, no, no. This is gay. And DGG, take
this [__] clip. Take it back to your
[__] dad. He wants to go jerk off and
[__] watch video games. He wants to
go [__] ass total spaz out. He does
come back. He does come back, guys. He
does come back.
>> [__] He wants to go half ass do
[__] tepid [__] commentary. Get
the [__] out of here. He doesn't have
anything better to do. He has nothing
better to do now. I don't know when
exactly it happens, but basically he
ends up um at some point, I think it is
around here, he like loses [__] mind
in DGG chat. I'm going have to find some
of the logs and he ends up blocking
Connor's embed. You know, on DG you can
embed streams. He ends up changing it so
you can't embed Connor's stream. Yeah.
So, he asks, "How how do I ban embeds?"
And then this happens. Thank you for the
50 sec. Thank you. All normal men has
had SBPDGF or had a friend disappear
because of one. No one who has seen this
want it again. Also, respect for Connor.
He grew.
>> Huge appreciate. Thank you. He's like
that's not a sweep. That's being
principled. Yeah, because you're
sweeping for something that was [__]
true. I'm not a pedophile rapist abuser.
It's just like I mean you so you've
engaged in sexual acts that people could
not consent to namely uh recording
people without without consent. Cherry
well allegedly okay but there's not
really any you know the idea there's a
reasonable [__] doubt in I'm very
skeptical of any other explanation other
than it's non-conceptual maybe cherry
numerous grinder hookups. So that that's
what people are saying there. You did
retain Cam and you have described some
15year-olds as being really [__] hot.
That's something you've said. If you
prefer heapile, whatever, man. And and
abuse, you have, like I say, you have
abused women. You have abused women. You
have abused women. Now, would would I
say if someone's calling Destiny a
pedophile, rapist, abuser, they're being
like honest or accurate? No, that's not
honest or accurate. But having
criticisms along these lines actually
isn't crazy. There's actually a lot of
evidence for that. It's a totally
there's there's a very reasonable
interpretations along these lines. It's
just the case. It just is.
>> Get the [__] out of here, puss. That
That was That was the weakest [__] That
was the weakest [__] that's ever [__]
happened.
>> [__]
>> He said he wanted me in here to talk to
me and confront me. Like I didn't even
get to talk. Like I'm more than willing
to talk to the guy if he's not running
away. Like
>> Well, next time
>> if he wants to come back, I'm I'm here.
Okay, Destiny. Um, yeah, just real
quick, DBY, why were you denying a few
nights ago that Wick was doxed in that
server by somebody posting his Wick, you
can verify this?
>> By the way, Wick, can you check your DMs
and verify what I just said? Does it
look like I'm lying about the
characterization of those messages?
>> This is what all this [__] [__] is
built on. Doobie says he doesn't think
Wick was docing there because he hadn't
seen it and that becomes a lie. That's
all he's doing every time.
>> Uh, give me a second.
Uh, yeah. Yeah, you said uh most of the
claims in that STREAM WERE TOTALLY LOST.
>> Uh I don't think any of these peoples
are doxers or whatever. Um uh I'm in
that snarkle left server. It's
absolutely not a doxing server. Um
>> I didn't read them out loud, but yeah,
cuz Yeah. Now DY will this guy's [__]
But yeah, so Duby, you were in public.
Yeah. What are you talking about? I just
I just repeated all that that when I was
there, I didn't say any of that [__]
And when you guys made the claim to Wick
that he was waiting,
didn't I Wick? Didn't I DM you? No,
>> didn't I DM you the moment that they
said this?
>> Okay, so
>> that last message is that one user was
banned. It was from the PV filing last
September that Hassan showed on stream
where Isn't that what you said, Dub? Was
that what was posted in that server?
>> That's my That's my current
understanding. Yes. And I told you to be
clear to be clear, what I saw was not
the PV docs. I wanted
>> Oh, then I don't know. So, so again, so
my holder in here to talk about stop
talking. Let me respond to let me
respond to my
accident. What I saw was not for the
149. Huge appreciate. Thank you.
>> That they got it from there.
>> I'm I'm still upset that you called me
[__] fat even though you don't lift
weights. I'm still upset about that.
>> So Wick again, I haven't seen So I
obviously haven't seen the image. I know
that it was like I know which user it
was. I don't know if I'm going to say
that,
>> but this is according to them. I haven't
seen I haven't seen any of it, right? So
like, but you like you can verify that
when they said this.
>> Why the [__] are you defending it?
>> Hold on. I my what I was defending is
what I've seen. Hold on. So Destiny
Destiny, can you tell me right now?
Destiny, can you tell me right now that
nobody has ever posted dog [__] in your
server?
>> I WOULDN'T DEFEND IT IF I IF SOMEBODY
HAD.
>> HOLD ON. What I was defending is what
I've seen the server to be and what I've
seen allowed in the server. I have not
seen this.
>> Doobie wasn't defending it. Die didn't
defend the doxing at all. At all.
Obviously, you would defend the
characterization of your server as a
doxing server, though, wouldn't you?
Because it's not about whether a piece
of PII gets posted. It's about how it's
handled and it happens allowed in the
server. It is not a doxing server. It is
a [__] flipping server. So, it's true
that that about a year ago, someone
posted something that they shouldn't. I
don't agree with that.
>> Keep filibustering.
>> You're okay. You're interrupting. I'm
trying to [__] respond. You dumb. Let
me respond and then you can go on your
[__] manic. It's fine.
>> Go for it, Dies. Keep going, Die.
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. Okay, Wick, just to
be clear, that's a what Dub said. Wick,
please correct.
>> Can we go one at a time? Stop. You both
names start with E. Destiny is correct
that what you said in those things was
incorrect. It was wrong. It was wrong.
Now, I will agree with Doobie when it
happened on stream. Dubbie did DM me and
said, "I would never dox you. If you
want me to if you show me it, I will
find the the people who did it and get
it removed and all that."
>> And then Wick, I understand. I even you
Wick and I love you. I know you're all
mind raped and I blame myself for this
largely. Okay, but Doobie or I'm sorry,
Wick, you understand that when he says
that he's just trying to find the leak,
right? I am when he goes through and he
says, "Wick, if you tell me exactly
where that came from, cuz you see how
all these guys have been swearing."
>> Just total nonsense. Literally total
nonsense.
>> The whole time saying that I am much
more likely to believe you because you
and Doobie lied to me. I'm saying I'm
saying when Doobie says that, they're
just trying to find the leak.
ridiculous Duby for the lie that Dubbie
is trying to spin right now in person.
And again, the reason why most of these
pedophile [__] won't talk to me is
because they can't spin these lies in
person because they're lying so much.
What Dubie just said was he didn't know
what it was exactly. Now, I think
personally I think that would be fair.
That's not what Dubbie said in that DM
though, was it? Dubbie didn't say,
"Well, I don't know what was posted. I
don't know." Doobie lied and said that
was just when Hassan posted his PV
stuff. Blah blah blah. How the [__]
would he even know that unless he's seen
something himself? And if he hadn't seen
the actual docks, which Wick, you
yourself say he hasn't, it means he got
the talking point mentally [__] into
his [__] brain by justical or Rio
Kitten House or [__] any of these
other [__] losers. That's exactly
what happened.
>> Okay, so he's on this.
>> What I said what I what I said was the
what I saw was not the PV doc. And yes,
in the DMs I was sent or the messages I
was sent, I don't know if they're DMs,
Dubie did say that it was. Now, whether
he lied or he was just grossly wrong, I
can't say. I can't speak.
>> Yeah.
>> Grossly wrong because he assumed that it
was the the most well-known docs. Also,
I'm not going to lie, like Wick keeps
referring to it as his he keeps
confirming it as his docs and telling
people where to find it. At what point
are you just linking them? At what point
have you just linked them?
>> Let me respond. Let me respond. Let me
respond. That's fine. So Wick, to be
clear, when I mess this up. So Wick,
when you when they said this to you, I
asked you what it was, where it was, or
who said it, so that I could try to find
their history on the server to figure
out if it was in there, if the user was
in there, etc. Right? Or if I think I
asked you which server, it's just so
transparent. They actually don't really
give a [__] And they're just
weaponizing it
>> because we know that the the leaks,
quote unquote, are coming from that
responsive.
>> That's fine.
>> Why did you say it was the PD? Why did
you say it was the PV doc?
>> Because that's what I thought. I can I
am not aware of any. Please stop
talking. Stop talking. I can tell you
why. Okay. Because my only understand my
understanding is that that's the only
time waste information has ever been put
out. I'm not aware of meeting doxs any
other time ever. So when I was told
>> you decided to put your reputation out
there.
>> Yeah. You know what they you know how
this could have been handled. If someone
thought Wicked been doxed in a server,
they approach someone who, you know,
hopefully they have some some trust in
or that they think they should have
trust in according to the server, report
it and see whether it get action gets
taken. If action's not taken, then
obviously that's a big problem. But that
would be the way to handle it to
minimize exposure. But no, they don't
care about minimizing exposure. They
don't care about the actual thing. It's
just a thing to weaponize. They want to
drag everyone into the same [__] mud.
the largest apparently cam collecting
discord on the internet.
I know you're really I know you're
really afraid of what I'm saying. Please
stop talking. I'm gonna listen to
anything you're saying right now. I'm
just going to wait for you to ramble on
and then I'm going to respond to it. I'm
not going to listen to any of this
random [__] that you're [__] saying
right now.
>> Keep rambling. Keep rambling.
>> Okay. Thank you. So So Wick, would I I
think with the wording wick and wick,
I'm totally fine with you showing those
DMs like if you want to like so you can
see people can see exactly what I
[__] said, right? So or or any of our
DMs like I don't have anything to hide
in there, right? So, um, uh, so what I
said is, uh, I haven't seen them post
anything near doxing there. When you
come up, it's typically memes about
eating noodles or some [__] I wouldn't
tolerate people doxing you. And then I
said, just figured out where it came
from if you want to know, right? Because
at that point, they they were talking
about it in the server and they'd
figured out that it was like posted in
LA like last September, right? And I
thought it was a PB doc. That's what I
thought. But they didn't when they found
it, they didn't post it. They just
banned the person that did it, right?
when they found they didn't they spam
the person that did it. My understanding
was it was that
>> but you understand that Destiny's
argument is that you were doing this in
order to to kind of triangulate who is
leaking these things.
>> How the [__] would that work?
>> But let it doesn't make any sense. So if
I take a screenshot of a Discord server
and then send it to you unless my name
is
>> people already figured I don't think I
don't know what time do sent his DMs. I
don't know that Dooby had any
conversation with people about this
before action was taken. It was just
action was just taken the moment it was
confirmed. Action was taken. That's it.
>> It's in the side chat or I'm replying to
something. How the [__] are we going to
know which user that came from?
>> Then why were you saying it was a PV
docs if you had no [__] idea?
>> I just told you.
>> Hey, everybody shut the [__] up. So, I'm
going to make this point with Destiny
here because Destiny says, "Well, maybe
Connor's kids could get docks based off
of this rationale."
>> Whoa. Whoa. I was only not prescriptive.
I know, but I was just being
descriptive, not prescriptive, Connor.
>> Okay, but I haven't doxed anyone, have
I? No, but I was just being describing.
>> What are you being descriptive about,
Destiny? Go ahead.
>> I'm just saying that you're creating an
environment that could facilitate
harassment towards unrelated third
parties by
>> But I'm not for this environment. I've
criticized this environment. I'm
criticizing you for helping to foster
this environment.
>> I know. I know that you're not for you
were just describing it and I'm just
describing your description. That's it.
>> Correct. Correct. Correct. Correct.
Yeah, we're good. We're good.
>> But you are actively engaged in doxing
people. We know that those people and
their families could get hurt as a
result of those reactions if you're not
[__] [__] And I'm criticizing
you for doing that. So, am I not trying
to get away from that environment?
>> No, you [__] [__] What a stupid
[__] If you were trying to get away
from it, you would probably disassociate
yourself completely from all these
people if you were a good faith actor.
But seeing as how this guy has a [__]
you with $5,000 or whatever the past 6
months, I don't know what your incentive
is right now. It's really [__] weird,
by the way, that I'm arguing with two
people that this weirdo on disability
child born consuming [__] is
literally funding. It's kind of a
strange [__] argument.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on.
Let's gohead. Let's go ahead AND DO
THIS. THIS ISN'T YOUR SHOW, WICK. Shut
the [__] up.
>> Conor, if you don't want to be
associated with it, you wouldn't be
associated with it.
>> NO, NO, NO. HOLD ON. Let's go ahead and
do this. Let's see if you're capable of
being honest. Let's see if you're
capable of being honest. Let's see if
you're capable of being honest. Let's
see if you're capable of being honest.
>> The question completely Can you steal,
man? Can you steal, man? Why Dubbie said
that he uh used uh child abuse material?
Can you articulate it without trying to
castigate him as a pedophile?
>> Have you ever seen the movie? Have you
seen the movie Casino?
>> I asked you a question.
>> I I'll answer if you answer that
question.
>> I Yes, I've seen Casino and I love it.
>> I would rather put my balls in the vice
that they used to pop that dude's eyes
out of his head and crush them steelman
anything this pedophile
a logging stalker [__] has ever done.
No, I'm not going to steal from their
perspectives. I'm not being a puss.
jerked off to see someone and held on to
it for a year. Like who the [__] you
calling a pedophile,
>> dude? Just dw
and he runs. And he runs.
>> Yeah, [__]
>> What are you talking about?
>> Nope.
>> And then held on to it for a year. Like
how? Why? Where do you think I've
>> Did he kick him?
>> I I'll answer if you answer that
question.
>> I Yes, I've seen Casino and I love it.
>> I would rather put my balls in the vice
that they used to pop that dude's eyes
out of his head and crush them steelman
anything. this pedophile
a logging stalker [__] has ever done.
No, I'm not gonna steal, man.
Perspectives. I'm not being a puss.
>> You jerked off to see someone and held
on to it for a year. Like, who the [__]
>> Okay. Yeah, I kind of kicked them.
>> Yeah, [__]
>> What are you talking about?
>> Nope.
>> Like, dude, you jerk off to see him and
then held on to it for a year. Like,
how? Why? Where do you think you have
any grand stand on calling anybody a
[__] pedophile?
>> I already kicked him.
>> What do you Oh, I'm sorry.
>> So, so hold on. Let me No, no, no. Wait,
my turn. Thank you.
>> You kicked him. Why? Why? Date
>> Destiny
>> actual [__] goblin
>> bigger has more viewers has more money
has more clout has more influence but if
he was a peer
>> [__] same size that's not how he
would behave if he was asked to steelman
somebody else's position and he was a 50
viewer Andy or 150 viewer Andy and Wick
forced him to as a debate moderator he
would steal man the other person's
position and all he's trying to do is
say Doobie is my enemy right now So, I'm
going to go ahead and paint him as a
pedophile, and I am incapable of
describing what he described in his
argumentation as once again, I I'll say
this straight up. As Destiny's fellow
content creator, thank you for the
content. Love the content. Love the
money. Thanks for the donations. Thanks
for the 10,00k live. As your friend,
you're being a [__] and I'm tired of it.
So, I'm about to rap in a second. Um, so
in seven minutes I'm gonna go. So
whatever your guys final arguments are,
please make them.
>> Uh, do you mean do you want to go first?
Do you want me?
>> I mean, again, I just I just really
think I need to hammer some like the
whole the whole thing is is [__] on
all sides, right? So people getting
locked, people going after Wix uh
panelists and whatnot. None of that is
acceptable ever, right? Um, none like
this is all gross. I really think we
need to tone down the [__] turn down
the [__] temperature, go back to like
sanity and there just need to be red
lines that everybody involved needs to
to have. And when those red lines are
crossed, the person who did it is
ostracized forever. It's totally no
tolerance for any of it. So that's
that's all I'm saying we need to do. I I
I think that's rational.
>> So I agree. But the way for this to
actually happen is the side that is
instigating it has to stop. The invaders
have to stop. If Russia stops and leaves
Ukraine, then Ukraine the war is over.
If the com the people, the communities
who are coming after me, who are coming
after my guests who are coming after
>> What do you mean the communities who are
doing it, dude? It's moderated. What do
you mean, [__] It's so [__] crazy.
>> The people who haven't been sufficiently
uh anti- Destiny, stop. This will stop.
That's it. That simple. Okay. And like
to be clear, I did send you a bunch of
evidence of Destiny and
>> I'll review it um later.
>> And to be clear, going for it. So I like
I said, I
>> will change nothing about his
perspective whatsoever.
>> Because I don't think the pressure
>> it's not about the facts, just about
people hurt his feelings.
>> It was fair, but and I know you're upset
with me because of the tweet, which I
still think
>> I think that you're being a kind of a
[__] to me. Okay. Frankly,
>> I I get it. So I don't I don't I don't
I'm not bashing you for that opinion. I
get it. And again, you and I have had
lots of disagreements about lots of
things. We don't exactly have like a
friendly rapport, right? But if you ever
want me stream or whatever, for whatever
reason, door's still open. I'm not like
opposed to like having being around you.
It's not nothing like that. Just FYI.
>> Okay. Um, thanks for letting me bully my
way into the conversation.
>> Die, that's nice and all, but I think a
lot of people are going to get
absolutely mollywoped reputationally,
financially, emotionally, and maybe
physically before all this is over.
>> Thank you for the $10, Jumbly. Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
>> Nope. It it was not fun. Uh it was fun.
It was fun in a content way. It was not
fun in a friend way. Uh but it is what
it is. At least we made some money and
got some viewers. I got other [__] to do
today. And so uh yeah, it is what it is.
So
I haven't seen anything. Uh people have
uh accused Dubbie of lying, which in my
opinion is not just being mistaken, nor
is it um it's not just being mistaken,
nor is it repeatedly restating the same
things four different times. If you are
incapable of understanding descriptive
from prescriptive, you're a dumb Oh,
yeah. So, let's read Destiny's Reddit
post quickly as well. This is what he
posts on Reddit when he's done with
this. changing changing some show
structures. Thank you for the
membership, Little Florida Jet. Thank
you.
Just as a heads up, here is the game
being played in the background across
several Twitch poll servers right now. A
whole essay post about Discord servers.
Kiwi Farms, the snarker sub and Discord
server, and several individuals whom
I've been involved with in the past,
JTO, Doobie, Queman, etc. have been
infiltrating and turning several
communities against me by repeatedly
debating for hours and hours and hours
for months and months and months. I'm
not exaggerating this unfortunately.
Same stupid talking points over and over
again. Okay, not I have not done that.
Now, even if I had explain the problem,
explain how it's different to what you
did to Hassan. Explain how that's
outside the bounds of reasonable
behavior to just argue what you think
about someone in Discord servers. Now, I
don't waste my time doing that. You
know, I've been in probably Jay talks a
few times where they've had debates
going on. I've argued it down. But
unless I'm on stream, I don't [__]
waste my time arguing down Destiny drama
with total morons. Okay, this has been
an active project they've all been
collaborating on for over a year, where
several people join Discord communities
to make the same arguments or shadow
people with money on stream to donate
negative or disgusting things about me.
I have the challenge of balancing how
much harassment and abuse I can take
from these communities while not
actually cutting them off because that
gives snarkers a big win. they can
permanently manifest there and continue
to rot that community and the people in
it until they also believe all the same
lies and smears about me. So
unfortunately today is probably a win
for them that managed to peel off Connor
and Marcus community is conquered as a
conquered one. It's about conquered. I
imagine the next big battleground we Wix
community. Nobody give a [__] about Wix
community bro. I mean I totally don't.
The talking points these people use will
revolve around several things. A few but
not not all of them being destiny is
routinely attempting to insnare mentally
ill women using his clout/ power. This
narrative almost universally started
from Mr. Lav and the fixation point on
this is anavoir and was a 30 plus years
old a master student pursuing a clinical
psychology career and was someone who
was relentlessly pursuing me the entire
time. So it's just like so dishonest
man. It was her that first messaged me,
her that suggested hooking up and her
that relentlessly spoke about me. Looped
due to OCD issues, I guess, for months
after. So, it's like because you because
she reached out first, there's no way
you could be using your clout or money.
That's not how that [__] works,
[__] Her relency for months
afterwards were my options for
responding were ineffective at getting
her medical treatment attention she
needs because she didn't because I
didn't handle this perfectly. People
described the most insanely malicious
intentions imaginable to me. So, this is
like insane. You behave. You didn't just
not hand it perfectly. You behaved
[__] horribly. You smeared her as a
stalker while you were still sexing her.
You held a string out in front of her,
pulling her along. You sent your
audience to her Kiwi Farms thread to
talk about her. You encouraged your
audience to call her employer in grad
school. Just like the examples go on,
dude. The examples go on. Desi is a
pedophile/ CP hoorder/ etc. This all
revolves around the recent court case
where instead of talking to an adult
woman, I found out a year in that I was
being honeypotted/catfished by catfished
by a member of Queenman's community for
2 years. So, this is just [__] He
came in to drop these [__] logs. No
idea who this guy was before that. No
indication he was around before that. I
think he used one gif that was relevant
to Bo Black's drama that happened very
recently to that point at some point
while he was around. That's the only
thing you can maybe say indicates he'd
seen anything else of me. And even then,
it's just the time to play the game
black guy thing. It's like quite a
widely used thing. But Alec G Alex
Gagway tweeted it around that time. It's
like the closest the closest you can get
to any indication that he was part of my
community until they finally leaked
everything on the internet hoping to
expose me as a pedophile because the
woman whose pictures he was sending me
was a victim he had pursued on a
platform for miners using a false
account and then later by threatening to
kill her and her family if she didn't
play along with his catfishing game.
Based on Desessie's behavior, his family
is fair game. I think it's justifiable
to unmask small accounts that have been
directly involved in harassing people
involved in my court case, doxing and
harassing people close to me and moving
in groups of users from server to server
to convince people of all the above. So,
I've literally done none of these. I've
l none of these. Doobie and other to run
around making the argument that is
therefore fair to stalk and harass my
child's mom. No one is saying that.
Doobie didn't say that. Dies against
that. You [__] liar. I need to
constantly weigh how much psychological
and physical pain and suffering I'm
willing to endure while allowing smaller
content creators to give a safe space
for these types of infestations to grow.
Following what I've been trying to do
over the past year or so, I'm going to
continue to try and enforce stronger
boundaries to prevent these types of
weaker creators from being around me.
I'd much rather cut them out and let
these eventually you fall to the crazy
obsessive/ snarky behavior that's taken
over them. I can deal with a lot of
negative attention against me and
personally personally and I've cut
enough of my personal life away to
survive a lot of the collateral fallout,
but I cannot continue to try and
maximally send to the feelings and
wellbeings of every single smaller
content creator I interact with. This is
so delusional, man. Well, they are
funded by and continue to host people
who have openly stated it is their goal
to destroy every part of my life and the
lives of the people that do not denounce
me. Sorry, two seconds. So, as of today,
I do not want anything to do with
Connor/C counterpoints. I won't upon any
panels or shows with them. I will
enforce my copyright against him. He is
reacting to my content in a
non-transformative way. I do not want
anything to do with him. I do not want
any contact with him in any way, size,
shape, or form. Maybe this changes for
future in the future if that snarky
community dies out or something. Dude,
waiting to flag him too to strike him.
On a personal level for me, and this
applies your own relationships as well.
I have made the mistake in past of
simply think it was prudent to continue
fighting my way out of all this toxic
fighting my way through all of this
toxicity. But I wasn't concerning
considering how much better life could
be by spending this time building
positive friendships with people who
will proactively defend you and your
reputation rather than me having to get
on my knees like a [__] loser and beg
people to simply slightly modify their
community to cut out people who devoted
their lives to destroying mine. Case
your community to me now idiot [__] and
you have no business in Twitch and
YouTube politics. Uh if you're saying
that I betrayed my principles for my
money. I'm sorry. Did I betray my
principles for my money when I was
accused of [__] sweeping for Destiny
last year and the entire [__]
internet was telling me to [__] torch
him? [__] you. You just don't like it
that I'm not on your team. So if you're
some [__] loser who doesn't
understand words but engages in
political tribalism, you can [__]
toos. So anyways, I'mma dip out. I'm
gonna read my super chats and I'm gonna
wrap my stream. So parasocial love,
guys. Talk soon. All right. Anyways, let
me thank the people who have donated.
Um, did Destiny pay? Lol. No, Destiny
did not pay. I got [__] to do. I got
[__] to do besides hang out with you
[__] Love you. Hate you. Everything in
every regard. I have to answer all the
[__] super chats before I get out of
here. So, like the stream, share with
your friends, engage with chat super
chats if you got a memberships. You got
them. I parasially love most of you. And
the snarkers who are being [__] and the
DGers who are being [__] can bazra.
Thank you for the gifted fashion 40.
Thank you for the gifted officer nasty.
My glorious overlord my king. I will no
longer behave in a way that upsets my
emperor. All mud shall be gone and shut
off for his own mental health. I don't
care. Uh I stand by pretty much
everything I said today. I think he
would have to show me a clip today. And
by the way, I'm not bridge burning or
bridge burning. He can bridge burn. I'm
not bridge burning. He can bridge burn.
If he's so [__] upset that I'm using
my reason to parse a uh parse apart the
arguments and evidence that's being
presented to me and he wants to bridge
burn the bridge over that, then [__]
him. He can figure that [__] out on his
own. But I'm not going to hurt him. I'm
not going to go out of my way to hurt
him. Nor am I even going to [__]
freak out about his whole thing like,
"Oh, based off of this rationale, you
could go after Connor's family. You
know, [__] you for that." Obviously,
that's rude as [__] but it is what it
is. He's f he's mad. He's sad. He's
lashing out. It is It is what it is. Uh,
silver for five says, "The bings will
continue until don's improve indeed." VS
Sunil, thank you for the 10, King
Tallybots with a five. How could you
need any additional evidence of
harassment? Who cares if they meet the
legal definition of doxing? I don't even
know if you know the evidence.
Tallybots, how do I need additional
evidence? Yeah. If you're going to be
doxing someone, you should know that
that person specifically engaged in
digital harassment. Is that so [__]
hard? Like like like what what do you
what do you want? You want me to say,
"Oh yeah, like [__] JTO deserves to
be raped, murdered, and dead in a ditch.
That's what you want?" You guys are
[__] You guys don't track words. You
don't pay attention to what words mean.
And it pisses me off. You literally just
identify emotionally with the political
tribe that aligns with your worldview.
And then you post hawk rationalize
whatever the [__] they said. And that's
cringe, gay, and lame. And it's not cog
behavior. Tribe for five says, "There is
something to be said about people being
involved in the court case without
putting their name on it. Doxing them
seems pretty fair. Not going to lie, is
it? And by that logic, should we dox
CFKA?" I I don't think that's a good
rationale at all. What the [__] Connor
is too pure and autistic for this world.
Nothing truer has ever been said. You
know says, "Pretty weird that snarkers
seem to always try to fracture
communities that care about liberalism
and conservatism. We can't let them
divide us." Well, we can temporarily. We
can just call each other [__] and then
we can go get a beer later. Valer says,
"Dubie and officer nasty are not in our
community without push back. We do not
allow either of them to run off without
a challenge. You are welcome to check."
Correct. So, I think we were accused of
something we don't do. Airborne kite for
10. Remember the old internet where you
could have a no o atheism debates in
here or your community would just become
an atheism fight club? It's like that,
but instead of atheism is does destiny
suck. I think that's a fair description.
Captain Dan the Fireman with the 10
bucks says, "Personally, this reeks of
allowing Nekrons to freely run within a
human colony, and it sounds like you're
saying no, they don't want our biomass,
>> dude. Bro,
oh my god. Oh my god. Why is this post I
just saw? Someone really needs to put
something together just explain all this
[__] man. So, we're not doxing, right?
I legitimately haven't seen it. I spent
most of my time in YouTube chat and
Reddit. It's been about a year or two in
the Discords a few years back. TBF, I
mean, no one's going to admit if they
did it. I haven't said it once in the
last six years in the community. How is
that going to be a claim? Is it that
hard to just believe we're a big
community? Like, it's so crazy. You are
just lost. They've been doing it all
over Twitter. They do it all over DG
chat. YouTube chat on Reddit. It's all
over DG. It's all over Twitter. So
crazy, man.
>> Well, Nekron. Yeah, Nekrons don't want
our biomass.
They don't. And there's allowing two of
them to rung a muck. Dude, they're two
scarabs. It's a scarab and a neckron.
I'm trying to think of an analogy that
would this would work. It's not a
warrior. Doobie would be a little bit
more salty than that. What would he be?
He would be an immortal. Yeah. I have
one pet neckron immortal and one pet
neckron scarab. And we're keeping an eye
on the scarab to make sure he doesn't
replicate. Yeah, I'm not allowed to have
a pet neckron. What the [__] Thought
this was America. Anonymous chatter for
50 says, "For the ban dubbie slush fund,
sincerely your third favorite oiler."
Well, thank you. Appreciate you. Captain
Dan the fireman for 10 says, "Ban the
Jean Steelers and be done with it." No.
And [__] you. Patriarch. Thank you for
the 10 gifted envoy snark for five. New
allegations. Who or where is Wick
accusing of doxing his guests? Don't
know. We'll find out. Captain Dan the
fireman for five. Well, don't you think
it would be wise to try and inform
someone so that anyone that's doing that
can be dealt with before any harm
happens? Don't you think that would be
wise? Or do we just want to use the sort
of stuff for sick owns? Because it
doesn't seem like you care about it if
that's what you're doing. [__]
Doobie was arguing that it was okay to
call up Destiny's son's future employers
about him. Dubbie is just a list. You
guys don't know what words mean, but
that's okay. Set a new goal, Booby Bear.
Little late for that anonymous chatter.
Appreciate you. Sir Rab says, "Dubie is
bankrolling destiny adjacent streamers.
Snarkers haven't targeted yet. Streamers
are either bankrolled or attacked.
Dubbie is the payment side. I think thou
dost presume too much." What if your
friends that are going to do retributive
violence on your behalf never get proof
positive of who did it? Do you think
they would do nothing? If not, isn't
this Destiny's reasoning for going after
his ops? Uh, if you kill me and then my
friends kill a few innocent people. It
is what it is. I'm dead. What do I care?
Bashion 445 says, "For the psychic
damage, Booby Bear, thank you." AK
Vatusai. Thank you for the 10. Jeb Kush
with a membership. Don't forget to like
the stream before saying something dumb
and get perma banned. True, true. Like
the stream before I twist your dick.
Kilo says, "There were not enough MS
Paint diagrams to stream. Do better."
True. Thank you. Anonymous for the two
says, "Sorry for being squirly. We don't
get much attention." True. V anonymous
chatter was [__] machine gunning
civilians today. Good job. Uh, whatever.
It's funny. Vosraka with the 10. Thank
you. I know it's not, but didn't tiny
show proof of Wick being doxed by them
to Wick. Sure, but I want to see the
evidence myself, don't I? And I want to
see the evidence of who did it, don't I?
Bazraa, thank you for the 10. Larry
Hutchinson, I know it's not you, but
didn't tiny showed proof of wick being
docks by them to wick. I think I just
read that one. Sorry. Gelatinous rude
pretend says, "Let's talk little St.
Jeff the next time the files drop. Don't
let these people hold threats of your
community or they will not stop." I'm
not. By the way, guys, I don't know if
you guys know what we're doing, but
we're not becoming snarkers, nor are we
becoming DGers. We're not doing either.
Okay?
>> And I'm not burning the bridge from my
side. Destiny is welcome to do whatever
the [__] whatever the [__] he wants
with his side of the bridge. I'm not
burning my side. He's been Destiny has
been a ruthless rude [__] to so many
[__] that if he was a ruthless
rude [__] to me and I use that as an
excuse to [__] him or try to [__] him,
then I would just be like everybody
else. And I'm not going to. I'm not
going to let his rage and anger and
[__] I'm not going to let his rage
and anger affect the way that I conduct
myself. I'm going to conduct myself the
way that I've always conducted myself,
which is I'm going to try to evaluate
what's correct based off of the
information that's in front of me. I am
not particularly susceptible to leverage
and you're just going to have to [__]
deal with it is what it is.
>> Connor
>> Molly Kagan for says, "Have you ever
watched a Ken Burns Vietnam War
documentary? It's excellent and a great
soundtrack." No, I haven't, but thank
you. Fashion 442 says, "If Destiny led
to you, would you burn the bridge?" Lied
to you? Nope. Nope. No offense. I feel
like Destiny has
>> Now, was that not like the most insane
crash out you've ever seen from Destiny?
That that has got to be the worst one,
right?
>> Southern, by the way. Uh, I feel like
they have lied by omission to me in the
past, but I understood what I why they
did so because I think that they were
worried that if I wasn't who I
represented myself to be, then I would
[__] them with the information that I
gleaned from their friendship. And I
want to be worthy of that trust. So, no.
Lying through omission, lying through
omission or lying through through
commission for good reason will not be a
reason why I burn the bridge. Um,
gelatinous rube doo be just that tiny
standards apply to him too maybe.
Minimum due for two says the circle jerk
is under threat. Get him janies. True.
That's all that's happened today. We all
agreed with Connor. Have you seen chat
friend? Have you looked at chat? Machico
for five flag eagle fire. Thank you. I
know you have to go live on valor today,
but was it possible we should go live on
your channel and charge people come up
and argue #bis bigbank or dollar sign
bigbank? Probably. But the content goes
where it goes. Um, Molly taking for
five. Obviously, giving people money is
kind of an influence and threatening to
withhold money in his attempt to
leverage such influence. Sure, but I
think that Doobie was saying, "I'm not
trying to influence Wick away from
covering debates. I just don't want to
incentivize Destiny being on your
platform." Larry Hutchinson for 20. And
I think that's his right as American to
do. Larry Hutchinson for 20 says, "The
risk of losing mod known. I can't be
called a DGER. This combo is kind of
dubious playing fast and loose with what
he says. trying to sell sweep and also
everyone except the cog has dirt on them
and has done dumb things. I don't know
if I read that correctly but I tried.
Thank you for the 20. Dubie has the
personality of a pea soaked paper bag.
That's very mean and I disavow. Eli Gray
for two says you should play my new
track at the end. I sent you. Where are
you? Where are you Eli? You're drowning
my DMs. Maybe I will. At the end of the
day, Dubbie has bad vibes. Bad vibes are
anti-gril hottest. That's true.
Infiltration of terror groups is a job
for feds. Okay. At least we can all
agree that Connor's biggest crime is
being shitty at OBS. True. K for 14
bucks. Describing something over and
over again is a way to promote it with
posible deniability. Okay. Does it make
the statement untrue? If I dox you and I
put your family at risk with a with a
barbarian retributive mindset or with an
eye for an eye uh eye for an eye tooth
for a tooth mindset, are you entitled to
dox and harass my family? Descriptively,
regardless of whether or not you like it
is yes, obviously diminish dark with
100. Thank you for the oil today, King.
You call me dad. I'm scared, but it's
okay. Thank you for the oil. Hi, can we
restart the entire conversation? I
arrived a bit late. Nope. Rewind the
VOD. Hail says Dubie. Can I have mod an
unbanned Terry for $5? Well, sorry that
Duby's gone. Real serious for 100 says
me right now. And the image I'm not
leaving YouTube to do this. Sorry, I'm
not looking at it. Chibdo one. Cheeto.
Cheeto. C H I D O 1 for 50 bucks. Thank
you. Regardless of whether or not you
love me or hate me today, I do think I
felt I feel like I brought the [__]
content. Didn't want to bring the
content, but I did. Hey, K2 for five.
Thank you. Airborne Kai for two. They
earnestly believe it matters if it's
true. Of course it matters if it's true.
But then you argue with them about
whether or not it's true. Jesus. Real
serious says this is kind of the reason
why vigilante actions are gay because no
one person has the final say on guilt
and culpability. We can understand that
Nazis with logic with this logic. So
correct. And I think Doobie's open
position even if he has some private
nefarious position is that he wants the
snarkers to stop [__] doxing and
harassing Destiny's family. And he wants
Destiny to stop doxing and harassing the
people who are criticizing him. Sz
Robert F for 200HF. Don't know what that
is, but thank you. Doobie, didn't you
just state that you'll never stop going
after Destiny until he learns his
lesson? What red line are you willing to
agree to? Uh, interesting.
>> I think Dooby's got like a real life
that he's not going to stop going after
Destiny until he learns his lesson. I
missed that part. Mr. Gene for five
says, "These people prove the existence
of smart dumb ninjas and it should be
studied." True. Tally bots with a
renewal. Thank you. What an anniversary
indeed. Ranger Nation for the five.
Destiny, this ends is everyone leaves
him alone. Jtock will not stop snarking
till Dan comes in and blanks me. Sweet.
That's what needs to happen for real.
For real. Um, Des or uh Dan needs to go
to Jtock and have sex with him. Ranger
Nation for five bucks says, "Why did
Hutch say this didn't affect him? Does
he not know the demons I know and
clearly work with? Laugh my ass off.
This can't be real, y'all." Literally,
go check the earlier coverage. I went
over that. I went over that. Molly
kicking for five says, I think she
should kick Dub calling Destiny a pedo
without evidence. Well, Destiny was
texting a 17 and a halfyear-old
allegedly, but was actually getting
catfished by a 26-year-old, which does
not make him a pedophile, nor does it
make him evil. So, but Doobie getting
>> Now, let's talk about the uh 15year-olds
at MLG or whatever the [__] he was
talking about those Skype blogs, of
course, getting evidence of law
enforcement [__] Um, you know, and
calling him a veto. I don't think that's
well evidenced either. My dude has been
incredibly bad faith about everything
with him. There's literally no
difference down to posting. Dude, if
you're going to call somebody a liar,
please give me evidence of them actually
lying. That feels like the the most bare
minimum of standards. If you're going to
call someone a liar, give me a link to a
stream that isn't identical to what
they're telling me to my face. Should
not be that hard. Jack Track 10. What
exactly did Destiny do wrong? Um, he
[__] with Muslims in a way that he
knew that he was going to get death
threats. Uh, he had sex with crazy
[__] women that he knew were going to
destroy his life. He continued to [__]
around with them after they started
destroying his life. He sent pornography
to somebody he just met. He sent
homemade pornography to somebody he just
met within 10 days. When the homemade
pornography got leaked, he started being
mean to all the people involved. Those
are Destiny's sins. Yeah, those are the
main ones anyways for me.
>> Descriptive is a weird thing because I
could say Dubia has occasionally
possessorate in the future me about
Thank you for the five.
>> Correct. Correct. To say that somebody
is a Vietong prolet if he wants to
copyright strike destiny and his dramas
throughout the years categorized by or
chronologically categorized by Mr.
And instead of like getting sucked into
each drama and drowning people with
information, um, this actually
summarizes all the drama through 2022.
And I think it's a pretty good video
essay. I think
>> was it just like I swear that one seemed
AI as [__] Thank you for the five
gifted, Chlorella. Thank you. And also
sweepy as [__] but hey, pretty sure he
sweeps like crazy in there.
>> It does capture an opinion prior to uh
getting all the [__] pixie [__] but
I'll I'll write a new one. I'm not going
once again. I'm not attacking Destiny.
That's not the point of this. And then
I'll I'll literally make a segment
calling him an Fler. How's that? And so,
as a result, I'm reliant on grassroots
hedgemon. I was like, well, that's
wrong. Here's half a dozen reasons why
people hate you. Like, I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. Are we seriously pretending that
there aren't good reasons to hate
Destiny? I don't hate Destiny. I don't
believe in the narratives about Destiny.
But are we pretending that his enemies
don't have a reason to hate him? You
guys are silly. No offense, Conor T. I
find it curious that you think anybody's
opinions would be different depending on
how many viewers they have. It's a peak
inside your brain and not in a good way.
No offense taking Connor. I just find it
curious that you think anybody's
opinions would be different depending on
how many viewers they have. That's 100%
true. That's 100% true. There are so
many You think all these slippery ass
[__] You think, seriously,
I'll demonstrate this to you right now.
Sorry, I still find this stuff
interesting even though I'm tired as
[__] Um, you think that all of the
[__] Destiny butthole tongue punchers
who [__] went deep into his
community, sucked up the Destiny on a
personal level, professional level,
sucked up the DGG, sucked up to that
community, and then soaked up
viewership. And then when there was a
mild inconvenience or there was
something that genuinely robbed rubbed
them the wrong way and they backstabbed
the [__] out of him in order to
temporarily maximize viewership and then
steal a chunk out of his community. You
think their opinions weren't affected by
viewership numbers? Are you crazy?
That's crazy pants. I'm over here
[__] with 50 to 150 [__]
watching geo [__] because one of my
biggest Oilers likes geopolitics. I
could have been over there [__]
sucking Stephen off.
>> Wait, what were you saying? Wait, what?
>> In order to temporarily maximize
viewership, sucked up to that community
and then soaked up viewership and then
>> Oh, you're saying I'm I'm a Destiny
traitor. Yeah, I don't think you can say
that. I always I was always clear what I
thought about the guy.
>> A mild inconvenience or there was
something that genuinely robbed rubbed
them the wrong way and they backstabbed
the [__] out of him in order to
temporarily maximize viewership and then
steal a chunk out of his community. You
think their opinions weren't affected by
viewership numbers? Are you crazy?
That's crazy pants. I'm over here
[__] with 50 to 150 [__]
watching geo [__] because one of my
biggest Oilers likes geopolitics.
>> Destiny over there [__] sucking off,
>> dude.
>> I'm the new Mr. Girl. Aren't we best
friends? Aren't we best friends? I'll
never betray you. I'll be your most
loyal arbiter. Aren't we best friends?
Aren't we best friends? That's what
could have been happening for the past
two years, you dumb shits. Is that what
happened? Obviously the [__] not.
Destiny and Lauren need to go settle
down. True. True. Young Lock says, "This
has been incredibly disheartening to
watch. I hope you're all good, Conor.
This [__] sucks." It's all right. Um, if
Destiny holds a grudge, maybe the bridge
is burned and we won't be friends in the
future. But if he's just having a bad
time and his court case is pressuring
him and he's [__] stressed out and
he's sick of people betraying him and
he's worried that I'm going to betray
him, which is why he's freaking the [__]
out,
>> um,
>> I'm just not going to punch back. I'll
turn the other cheek. I'll just turn the
other cheek.
>> Call banning Doobie and banning [__]
fulfilled. the unreasonable [__] talk
[__] talk about me or I will no longer
associate fraternized debate or talk
with you. That's a reasonable ask. I
shouldn't permit people in my community
to endlessly [__] talk Destiny.
Unreasonable ask since I Destiny have a
disproportionate amount of clout and
power in spite of slash because of uh
rudeness. It is safer to ban snarkers
entirely so you do not warrant my wrath
and disassociation. Not only did mutton
confirm that this was the implicit
threat underneath the reasonable ask,
Destiny fulfilled the unreasonable ask
today. So, anybody who said I think it
was Patriarch, wasn't it a patriarch?
[__] patriarch. It was somebody.
Somebody said, "Oh, that's a straw man."
And then came on and said, "No, that was
the implicit threat." And then Destiny
came on and executed this threat. If if
I would have just said, "You know what?
Doobie is a bad guy. Officer Nasty are
bad guys. They're gone. We don't need
that kind of drama in our lives." Poof.
I don't give a [__] about evidence. I
don't give a [__] about due process. I
don't give a [__] about fairness. You
guys are hanging out with bad people.
Therefore, you're gone. [__] you. We
wouldn't have even had this fight. I
literally could have done that. I could
have done that. You think there would
have been a drama about me just banning
Doobie and banning [__] Officer Nasty
because they were snarkers. I could have
done that. But I don't respond well to
people throwing their [__] weight
around. Destiny threw his weight around.
That [__] doesn't work on me. So, good
luck. Good luck with having people who
you can leverage into sucking you off
metaphorically or literally. Good luck
with that being your close inner circle.
I've seen it before. I will see it
again. that when you insist that your
inner circle do nothing but suck you
off, you are going to end up with
nothing but sick of brownnosers who will
eventually backstab you. Steven is in a
hell of his own creation, and I can't
save him. I wish I could save him, but I
can't. So, good luck. Uh, Connor, you
are and always will be my friend named
that sci-fi franchise. Barscape, I don't
know. I'd be triggered if you call me
fat, too, but yes, Connor, yes, you're
almost there. Isn't it strange how many
of these idiots act like scorned women
after Destiny disagrees with them once?
Yes. You know why? Because, of course, I
want clout, power, and money. Of course
I do. Everybody in the space wants
clout, power, and money. But I'm not
willing I'm not willing to uh become a
[__] for clout power and money or a
[__] backstabber. Going to miss you,
Connor. I understand has some stuff to
be critical about, but these snarkers
are insane. It's all good. Happens to
the best of us. Bro, that is a terrible
analogy. All right. They're not
sympathizers. They're active
participants. Prove it. [__]
>> [__] slaves. [__] slaves.
>> Harassers. He sent the [__] porn,
right? It's not whether or not they have
reasons. It's whether or not those
reasons are literally. And what would
that change? What would that change
about what I've said? What's
embarrassing about DG? We got like a we
got a thousand people live which is
crazy. Um but we got a thousand people.
What would the snarkers doxing me
change? You guys don't think about the
words that you're saying. You don't
think about like Okay. Okay. I'm milking
this a little bit admittedly. I need to
[__] dip out at some point.
>> Stacking paper.
>> Doxing me change.
>> Wonk.
>> It wouldn't change a [__] thing. I
never made the argument no snarkers have
ever doxed Destiny orbit. It's never
been a statement I made. You guys are a
shadow of what I thought you were. And
it's sad. Okay, dude. He's having
literally having the same moment
everyone else has had this week. I had
it. Aiden had it. I saw Freddy Wood
saying he had it. He's having the same
moment. It's just Dude, I just can't
believe what my perception was. It
wouldn't change a [__] thing. I never
made the argument no snarkers have ever
docked Destiny or his orbit. It's never
been a statement I made. You guys are a
shadow of what I thought you were. And
it's sad. Okay. What I thought you were
was I thought that you were a community
of
>> Yeah, I thought everyone's Well, we
quite have kind of had that moment
before, but this is just like so bad.
This has just been so [__] bad.
Employed above average intelligent
people who like to argue on the internet
about politics. That's what I thought DG
was. And then I thought that you love
Destiny and you do. That's pretty clear.
It's pretty clear you guys love Destiny
and I appreciate that about you. But I
thought that what you loved about
Destiny was that he was smart. He was
rhetorically gifted. He was capable of
thinking on his feet. He was capable of
analyzing facious arguments within a
debate and calling them out as they
occurred. He was capable of
differentiating between descriptive and
prescriptive statements. I thought
that's what you loved about him because
that's what I love about him. I love
that he is smart enough to catch
[__] on the fly and call it out.
>> But sometimes he does have bad
performances and often times when he has
bad performance because he's winging it,
he himself is engaged in facial
argumentation. He himself is incapable
and I know that he's capable of
understanding the difference between
description and prescription because
most of the people in online politics
learn the difference between description
and prescription from destiny. So I know
he knows the difference. But when I get
into an argument with him and I show
him, Dubbie is being descriptive, not
prescriptive. And he says, "Well, it has
the stocastic effect of prescription."
And I say, "Hey, Dubie, are you making a
prescription?" And he says, "Nah."
Because the prescription is [__]
crazy. The prescription is Nathan
deserves it. That's the prescription.
That's [__] crazy. So you guys say
he's just hiding his power level. Show
me. Show me. That's your assertion.
Doobie is hiding his power level. Show
me. And why would I walk that back? Why
would I take your word for it?
Especially when all of the argumentation
that's come in today from DGG has
[__]
>> Dude, Jimy, no way. This is This is a
crazy leak. I had that moment when
Destiny made a separate mod discord in
the wake of the nude scandal and was
desperately asking us about the
temperature in his own Discord and
others. Very weak. very desperate
sucked. It's sucked. It's been terrible.
You guys should be [__] ashamed to
call yourselves DGG. You're not. You're
not a Twitch and YouTube political
community made up of the smartest
undermployed [__] who are fans
of one of the best internet debaters on
the [__] planet. You are [__]
cultists and it's sad.
>> Enjoy your perma, [__]
>> What evidence would you accept? Any.
Any. You claimed Dubbie was lying to my
face and then you sent me a clip of
Dubbie saying exactly what he said to my
face.
>> Conor, did you literally not believe the
Earth was round because you've never
personally been in space before? You're
[__]
>> Bye.
>> I on an individual level when it's a
group malicious actor coordinating tax.
It's more complicated. Okay, go back to
my Vietnam analogy. Misread my comment
and call me dumb. Okay, bye. See you.
What is this grouping mentality? This is
the internet, bro. Everyone has like 30
communities. Laugh my ass off. I don't
know. I don't know. They're being f
slurs. DDD for life. See, can we get
some Indian pride going? I don't I don't
like the Indian hate. Can we get some
[__] Indian pride going?
>> I am Indian. I am Indian.
>> Think green lights. Do you Do you think
this is all just random or only KF? Do
you think J has any role in this at all?
Maybe. Show me evidence. Show me
evidence. I'd love some evidence. Please
show me some evidence.
>> I am Indian cultist now. He's got the
points.
>> Have you ever considered that you guys
haven't fored a good argument all day?
>> India.
>> You guys could forward a good argument.
You could say, "Hey, Connor, here's a
link of a video of Dooby lying." That
would be perfect. I'd love that. I would
love it. Hey, here here's a video. Uh,
here's screenshots. Here's screenshots
of the claims we're making, but you
don't have anything. Thank you for the
Indian Pride people in my chat. I love
you. I just don't understand why you
defend to Dubside instead of assuming
that Destiny can back up his claims
because that's not how any of this
works. I've been in Twitch and YouTube
politics for 6 years. You don't make
claims if you can't back him up. So, you
don't get to say Doobie, Quean, and
Jtock are doxers who are coordinating a
life ruination campaign in order to
destroy me and don't have any [__]
screenshots.
>> Y'all bless. Love this guy.
>> Yeah, I heard uh last night. I almost
watch it.
>> We love it.
>> You know what was crazy was implying
that Dubie was a pedophile for reporting
people to law enforcement. That was
crazy. You know what was also crazy?
Calling Saiba a groomer when he there's
no evidence of him trying to extort
sexual favors from other either Kelly
Jean or uh Rose. So yeah, when you start
using hyperbole in order to make your
argumentation without evidence, you're
goddamn right I'm going to get [__]
skeptical. You're goddamn [__] right.
The Vietnam analogy works. However,
you're saying he's attacking citizens
and his argument is he's just going
after
>> Why is that chat message?
>> But when I asked him, "How is esports
Batman a combatant? How is Supreme a
combatant?" He didn't have good answers
for that, did he? DG, are you going to
change your mind? Since I have your
attention, I got a,075 people. Are you
going to change your mind? When the
manifesto comes out and there's no good
evidence that esports Batman was a
combatant and there's no good evidence
that Wicked Supreme was a combatant, are
you going to change your mind? I'll be
happy to eat. I'll be happy to go. Oh
[__] Wicked Supreme was Wicked Supreme
was stalking and harassing Destiny's
family members. Holy [__] he deserves
to get doxed. Oh [__] Caiba. Well,
actually, I understand Cyba. Never mind.
Forget I said Caiba. Oh [__] Esports
Batman wasn't just providing legal
analysis to JStock. He was in Jtock
servers using public databases to better
Doc's Destiny. Oh my god, they were
right to doc esports Batman. I would
love to say that. I'd love to say that.
I can't wait to be wrong. I would love
to be wrong. Guys, quick quick quick
reminder. Quick reminder, guys. This
this is this important. This quick
shill. Um, go subscribe to the YouTube
clips channel. Okay, lots of shorts over
there. Okay, guys, if you're a shorts
watcher, great place to be. Okay, just
shilling that quick. Go sub, guys. Go
sub. Did I listen to argument about the
kid? Yes. Do you know what descriptive
versus pcripted is? Holy [__] You guys
are You guys are the worst generation of
DG to ever exist. You know what I'm mad
at Destiny for? I'm not mad at Destiny
for threatening to copyright strike me.
I'm not mad at Destiny for saying he's
not going to be my friend anymore. I'm
not mad at Destiny for being crazy in
his personal life. I'm not mad about any
of that [__] You know what I'm mad
about? I'm mad about the fact that this
is the dumbest generation of DGG that's
ever existed. That's what I'm mad about.
I'm going to do something that Destiny
should do for you. But he's not for some
reason. Descriptive definition, an
explanation of a word, concept, or term
based on how it actually is. Wait, hold
on. Wait, hold on. Let me read it word
for word. A descriptive definition is an
explanation.
>> Yeah, legit, it is just the cultists
left. It is just cultists left. word,
concept, or term based on how
>> everyone else who was there actually
believed something he said at some point
and had enough cognition to notice when
it was contradicted. So then so they're
sort of done with it, you know? They're
sort of done with it because you can
only have that happen so many times
before you're like, "Oh, wait. [__] this
guy." Unless you're a complete [__]
cultist.
>> It is actually used in practice and
observation rather than imposing strict
rules. It documents reality as it is,
focusing on observable facts, traits,
and common usage. prescriptive
definition. Daddy Destiny should have
already explained this to you. So kind
of sad that I have to do it. Something
that dictates, recommends, or
establishes rules and norms for how
things should be or ought to be done
rather than merely observing or
describing how things currently are. Go
back to what Doobie said today, to what
Dubie said in DMs, to what Dubie said
during Destiny's coverage, and to what
Dubbie [__] said to Wick and ask me,
don't even ask me. Tell me, is he being
descriptive or prescriptive? And does he
differentiate between description and
prescription? You guys are the worst
generation of DG. It's really sad. It
makes me sad how far you've fallen,
>> bro. I fail.
>> Be chatting for hours and hours and
hours about how it's okay to do this to
Destiny as him approving of it. Show me
that.
>> Absolutely. Real as [__]
>> I'm 1085. Here we go. You know what I
got? It's 5:11. I will 100% be gone by
5:30. I'm just enjoying having 1100
viewers. So, here we go. Let me go ahead
and send you a Discord invite. Love to
see that. I would love for anybody to
send me. And we have all of these
screenshots. Thank you for the DM, but
unfortunately that's unrelated. Good.
Thank you, you dork. And I DM Doobie.
That's on Twitter. Interesting. Let me
DM this to Dubbie. Let me see if this is
Dubbies. This is the closest thing we
got. I love it. Don't you love how I
love evidence? Dubbie. Omni Doobie.
Doobie. Comrade Dubovich. That's a fake
DM. Laugh my ass off. Hold up. Let's say
this. Uh, hold on. That's not my
account. Laugh my ass off. Okay, it's
AI. You son of a [__]
That was so rude. That was so rude.
Literally one of my own community
members AI generated a doobie tweet
where he endorsed
God. Yeah, he did Palestine to get in
and grilling himself alive to death. Bad
were snarkers who pretended to be DG to
gay op. And by the way, I don't trust
any great names. I don't trust any of
you. He gets paid nothing from YouTube
from what I understand for several
months to keep being wrong. What does
that mean? So why not wait for the
manifesto or refrain from stating your
opinion until the evidence is released?
Isn't it snaky? Oh, that was that
[__] Ape Gamer [__] Ape gamer
pretended to be a DJ and sent like how
your [__] email or some [__] was like
so stupid.
>> What's sneaky about saying, "Hey,
Destiny, if you're going to dox people,
you should know that they're the people
who are digitally harassing you." I'm
sorry. What's sneaky about that? You
need them to say they endorse it? That
was a claim made in chat, you dick [__]
If it went around saying and arguing for
>> hours ban over that, but it's just like
so [__] [__] Yeah, a guy
absolutely chewed out for that. Exactly.
Literally, everyone told him, "You're a
[__] clown."
>> to heat their children, but I don't
endorse it. You believe me? You guys
suck. DG is not sending their best.
Snarkers are not sending their best.
Saying that Destiny is withholding the
manifesto for views is a pretty rat [__]
interpretation and shows how you were on
dub side from the start. Have fun with
your whale. What do you think DB do you
think Destiny would deny that he wants
to create a beautiful manifesto in order
to rape his opposition? Hasn't he said
so as much. Okay, this guy was skitso.
I'm done here. Dude, you came here for
today. You're a gray name. This is the
first and last time that I'll see your
user handle. I'm sorry. Hold on. I
should be clear about snarkers and or
DJs who are doing gay odds in reference
to, oh my god, Connor's lost his mind. I
can't watch him anymore, but you're a
gray name. Okay, you see all the blue
names and the green names. The green
names are people who have been around
during the mass gifted memberships of
Patriarch and Grassroots Hedgeon. Those
are all the green names. All the blue
names are people because I have a small
community of 50 to 150 people. All the
blue names are people who have been
interesting, smart, or cool enough for
me to say you're a regular and I like
you and I don't want to ban you. So, I
made them blue. So, if you're gray and
you come in and say, "I used to be the
biggest fan of Counterpoints until
today. I am taking my Patreon off and I
will no longer be donating to this
channel." You're a loser. To come on,
guys. It's not looking good. 528. Got
two minutes left. Stick terrorist. He's
ancastic terrorist. Can show me the
screenshot. Like him too much. It
happens. Why you acting like viewers are
circus monkeys? I need to dance for you.
You don't have to. Bye. Because DG is
would deny that he wants to create a
beautiful manifesto in order to rape his
opposite decimon.
Those are all the green names. All the
blue names are people because I have a
small community of 50 to 150 people. All
the blue names are people who have been
interesting, smart, or cool enough for
me to say you're a regular and I like
you and I don't want to ban you. So I
made them blue. So, if you're gray and
you come in and say, "I used to be the
biggest fan of counterpoints until
today. I am taking my Patreon off and I
will no longer be donating to this
channel." You're a loser. POS. Come on,
guys. It's not looking good. 528. We got
2 minutes left. Somebody made a DG made
a bold assertion. They made a bold
assertion. Dudy's been Dudy has been a
stcastic terrorist. He's been a
stocastic terrorist trying to annihilate
Steven from orbit online for months.
He's been advocating for Steven's
destruction publicly for months. I've
been waiting for 18 minutes for a
screenshot. And you got 60 seconds left.
You got 60 seconds to show me the
screenshot. Can someone hide behind a
script saying I came to avoid hand while
creating script outcomes? Absolutely. W
Connor, that's the one person who said
it. Caramel Bruce says, "Hey Con, I
tried like too much happens." Why you
act like the viewers are circus monkeys?
I need to dance for you. You don't have
to. Why? Because DG is making bold
claims and they're not backing it up.
Every time DG here is actually a
snarker. True. That could be true.
Opposition gay ops. Yep. Calling him
Ahab the way he's chasing whales. True.
I've been reasonable all day. All right,
Elon, here you go. Here's your standard
moderator. Don't make me regret it.
Emperor of Ela, I know you. Here you go.
Here's some wrenches. Rob's a boss, but
he pissed me off recently, so I'm going
to leave him demoded. Suck it. Rob's a
boss. Scribble sponsor man. I'll be
honest. You were nobody to me who was on
many other streams. I came here to see
what was up because no one I actually
watched was live. You've lost the plot.
Okay, bye. See you. You don't need to
watch. I'm a regular and you've lost the
plot. I've never seen you ever before.
I say I say um Molly says, "What color
is my name?" You're blue. Prescriptively
or descriptively? That's funny. Okay.
Yeah, this is pretty boring.